yeah that smell like transmission fluid
ask them when you open it you're like oh
god
dog you eat these [__] things people
tell you how do you eat four i told the
lady at perennial that you ate two of
them the other day she was like
i can't even imagine that she goes i get
a square
and cut it into twos yeah and i go she
goes i get [__] up for four or five
hours straight but you know what's weird
i had what did i have i had three of the
red stars last night that's just 3.75 i
have 375 just to warm up for nothing i
got pretty high for like four hours yeah
it hits you but then it goes away real
quick right yeah absolutely it
disappears real fast yeah we burned
through these stars we our main edible
are the stars so we built the tolerance
to them like most people could eat one
red one and they get they see but i mean
isn't it thc though because like i have
i have an extreme tolerance to smoking
like i can [__] smoke yeah dude i
could smoke all literally all day i just
the only reason i don't do it anymore is
because like my throat will start to
hurt yeah i'm not getting no weight i'll
get a headache you know that first high
in the morning is my best i got super
high in the morning i tell the little
things i have to do while i'm high
if i hit it again i get a little high
but once i come back from jiu jitsu
i hit the pipe maybe once do you ever
you ever take a break just to get really
highly or because i sometimes i took
that break for like six months and how
did it work oh no to when i came back i
got really [__] up
yeah for a week you're [__] stoned
you're eating your fingers yeah it's
great ready i'm ready let's do this
let's do this [__]
we want to we want to start yakking
while the [__] things hit you
the church of what's happening now is
presented by on it
this show is also brought to you by hint
water
go to hint.com
church and check out hint water hint
water
is a brand new water that brings you the
fresh taste of fruit with pure water
and right now when you go to hint dot
com slash church you're going to get a
variety pack of their most popular
flavors for only 15 dollars it's
normally 24 drink hint dot com slash
church
show is also brought to you by meundies
go to meundies.com joey right now to get
20 off of your first order shipping is
always free in the us and canada go to
meundies.com joey right now check out
their shirts their socks their underwear
i love their sweatpants go to
meundies.com joey right now
here we go
mr gomez is in studio
kick that mutely don't make me tell you
again kick that [__] i don't
care what the animal society says
kick that [__] thursday night
december 8th what
oh [__] jews up and jumping up and down
you got [__] 16 more days to yom
kippur or hanukkah one of those
[__]
one more star going we're at 1600
milligrams paul ripley call his mother
called guinness
it's the church of what's happening now
[__] oh [__]
black people jumping up and down
oh [__] break out the gorilla biscuits
here we go do it do it mr g
what you did to me cause i'm not the
same oh [__]
you just don't know
oh [__]
you wanted you got it [__] we've been
doing bong hits stars of death
we've been taking good care of mr gito
we don't want to kill him tonight we
want him to make the plane tomorrow
i i'm you know what i keep on getting
warned about this show
over that's the one thing i've gotten is
like listen to me don't have anything to
do after the show
make sure your flight's not too early
the next day don't drink the water
because joey might put acid in it
there's all these we can't find the acid
we got rid of by mistakes i don't think
so i think you put it in some waters
it's like the willy wonka ticket but you
just put some acid in some random
there's like seven [__] hits of
coin acid in this room
in one of these bottles of water no it's
probably another one of those couches i
hit it
and i can't remember where the [__] i
hit it because we didn't we got paranoid
so it's in one of the album covers it's
here though yeah one day somebody's
gonna be very happy i was moving
furniture one time with dave smith we
used to be roommates he's a comedian and
one of my co-hosts in my other podcast
and uh
he uh we were moving our couch
and as you're moving it on the day
removing a bag of cocaine fell out of
the couch like probably like you know
like an eight ball
um and it was me having our buddy wes
and literally we all stopped we saw it
fall on the floor we all paused for
exactly one second and then we dove for
it all three of us and we wrestled
around on the floor until one of us
finally got it
um and then we just shared it but we did
a one we did a line each immediately and
then we felt guilty because we didn't
really do cocaine it was a buddy of ours
our drug dealer friend jablonski
he would [__] come over with like
tons of drugs all the time and he
accidentally dropped it on our couch it
was like a year old
so then we felt guilty and then we ended
up flushing it down the toilet the rest
of it you should have sold it yeah we
split 60 a piece something i mean how
would we have sold it i don't know
there's some [__] money in the comedy
club that'll give you 50 bucks yeah but
it's not it's not enough if it was like
a big bag of cocaine there's no way we
would have flushed it like all right
let's [__] figure 3 grams somebody
would give you 50 bucks right yeah but i
would have had to go out and [__] be
hawking weird at comedy clubs no i
wasn't still i wasn't doing comedy you
have one friend that does coke everybody
has one creepy friend that does coke
just call a [__] i got a deal of a
century i think i have one friend that
doesn't do coke yeah so you call that
don't call him
call everybody else and go whoever gets
here first has his deal of ascension
bring 50 bucks
and watch them come over
it's [__] crazy yeah i found the bag
of coke once i thought it was like
meeting god
you know what i'm saying like i'd rather
find you you have more chances of
finding money yeah than finding like two
grams of [__] blow like you go to
7-eleven that's what it was yeah it was
ten years ago at the curse on seven
eleven and the [__] up thing you
remember the day oh my god i went in
there and i went in there the other day
they had the audacity to put the liners
back up
they used to have other foul lighters i
used to clip to a [__] pop right in
front of them while i was paying they
looked down i take two and just hold on
is this recently
no this was 10 years ago but they put
the lightest back this week because i
went in there tuesday yeah and i said oh
[__] they got the liners back on i was
ready to clip one yeah i'm like oh why
[__] around at this point in the game i
don't you just kind of want to because i
do that sometimes just to test my
ability still
if i could just like my cousin just for
no reason i do it all the time for
stupid [__] like i was i was the other
day i was with my chick and we were at
uh rite aid and there's like nail
polishes
at the front thing so for no reason
right in front of the check as i'm
paying i grab one of the nail polishes
put it under my hand i said i'm palming
it that's what i'm doing not a big deal
putting it in your hand like you're
reaching for money just nothing and you
drop the [__] thing and you take out
the wall and they look at you like
no he didn't have no nail polish
nice and simple put it in my [__]
crazy it's like houdini i walk outside
give it to her as a nice little gift you
know and i'm being funny which is she
doesn't want nail polish nothing but for
some reason i still want to be able to
test my ability to see if i could do
that
and i could i still do it i still it's a
terrible [__] i don't shoplift like
bags of chips i got an addiction for
just lighters
just lighters if you're dumb enough to
put a lighter in front of me i'll take
the space i go the 7-eleven i go to has
little lighters out
they even put like when they overflow
down lighters they put they put them
sideways yeah which is like an
invitation for a sucker like me but i
like them so much if i asked them pill
why they'd probably give it to me so why
rob them you know yeah i i i'm notorious
at stealing people's lighters like in
life by state yeah yeah
mistake on purpose not on purpose i
don't care enough to give it back to him
you go out with a green light you come
home with a white lighter yeah and it's
filled and you're like who the [__] took
my life at least i came home with a
[__] life yeah that's the magical
weed that's why you are connected with
weeds sometimes because sometimes you go
out with a red lighter
and you come home with a green light and
you're like what the [__]
i don't i didn't lose anything maybe a
little bit of [__] butane you know
you're looking pale over that dog
i haven't seen you this pale since the
first time you did kettlebells
i'm just thinking about
having so much coke that you don't
realize you dropped an eight ball like
i've i've never found
like that i couldn't imagine you're
[__] up losing drugs you're [__] up
you're going through your pockets you
know you got an eight ball in there you
got a gram for later you got three pills
in there you got cash you got weed you
got rolling papers you got a lighter you
got a wallet and it's all in there and
you take it out all night because you're
paranoid
all night you're like where's that coke
and one time when you go for the coke
the three ecstasy pills will fall out
vikings if you're gonna take money out
of your pocket and then yeah it happens
man yeah you know i've dropped coke on a
[__] couch or or the move was uh
you're doing it in the bathroom you put
it down on the the thing in the bathroom
and you forget you put it down and you
leave and that's it then the next dude
is taking a [__] just as watching
amazing you said that because i was just
thinking about
this chinese restaurant i used to
deliver food from deliver coke for
and they had like a bat they had like
two bathrooms for customers then they
had a bathroom for chinese people only
were they
then they had another bathroom for the
women in the back but if you went
backpack back in the storage room they
had a little bathroom
with a little look like a closet it was
just a toilet and a sink
and i would go in and weigh the coke
and i would put the coke on the toilet
it was white
and do a couple lines and get ready to
deliver chinese food
and one night i must have been in a rush
i came in two days later away coke and
there was a lion this big on that
[__] thing that unless you have a
train die yeah you're not going to see
that wow unless you have a
cocaine-trained [__] guy
and nobody that did drugs they smoked
pot from time to time so yeah what's up
lee well you guys were talking earlier
about and i only did it once flying with
weed and the only time i did it
i i had some edibles i was flying home
and i got too paranoid like you've
always talked about how you just put it
underneath the plane like you like
before when you used to go back and
forth between colorado and new york i
was too nervous i was like i don't want
to get there and then have them take my
luggage so i brought it in my backpack
but this is the only time this has ever
happened that tsa brought a second a
separate like scanner to the gate and
they were scanning random people at the
gate i was i couldn't have been more
scared that's an email right there oh my
god and then i got and then i thought
about you i got pulled over today and
like i just
i just i was so happy i wasn't stoned or
i i've never been have you been pulled
over stoned oh it's horrible oh
you start [__] mumbling and stumbling
i was doing that was the one thing that
i liked about stopping smoking weed it
was like six months that i didn't smoke
weed like and you and i forgot but like
i used to always have wheat on me and
new york city it's you know it's gotten
a little better but like it's not cali
dude callie you guys are [__] like
partying out here it is like you don't
even get it dude you go to [__] new
york city bro i lit up one time and 20
people looked at me like i was a martian
yeah you're it's that by opian anthony
right right down there it's like a
[__] criminal dude you know me i took
a joint of course [__] people were
looking at me
even in jersey when i'm in edgewater i
go outside and just not like that cali
it's like you guys don't know how good
you have it if you haven't been to new
york if you go to new york city you are
it's like you're doing heroin i'm
assuming if you did heroin on the
streets of california it's how people
look at you if you're smoking weed in
new york city let me tell you something
okay i was in new york city since 19
[__] 66.
you know
as a kid my mom took me to see the home
globetrotters 42nd street i went
everywhere
and there was a time in new york city
this is how new york how much new york
has changed
okay there was a time in new york city
when i was a child maybe six
from the age of six to maybe 11 and i'm
not exaggerating it
i spent my time within 88th street and
broadway that's where i went to school
ps166
but on the weekends i'll go to my
godmother's 148th
in the late in the mid 70s and this is
no exaggeration ask your dad or your
uncles or somebody who remembers the 70s
in new york
you'd see a [__] heroin dude nodding
every four minutes i used to see it in
new york okay and i mean they were
everywhere yeah it was infested the
upper the upper west side i was wasn't a
big upper we east side guy so i can't
tell you yeah i used to go to 116th and
third like by the park to get coke from
my mom's friend but that was later on in
life nothing
heroin was a everywhere that's what you
saw
from a hundred and seventh street all
the way to 178 from port authority they
would nod as the light was changing mr
gomez not and when the light would
change they would walk across the street
and not again yeah you would never it's
like walking dead that's what it was you
saw two walking dead people on every
[__] block but downtown new york all
those other west side up the you know
8th avenue you would smell weed all the
time when i was yeah
42nd street would wreak a [__] weed
nobody ever said no rika weed yeah when
you made the right answer and you saw
that thing spinning with the news the
ticker when you made the the left onto
broadway whatever that is that would all
that would be a drug dealer hell yeah
that was all drug dealers
then
the 80s came
in the early 80s
you could do blow anyway in new york
yeah
any club you went to if you went into
the women's bathroom
there was four or five people doing blow
women wouldn't even say nothing
women wouldn't even say nothing it was
that open
i left new york in 85 and cocaine was
wide open you could be at a bar
in manhattan and take a package out and
do this and nobody would look at you
nobody would look at you weird because
that yuppy
mentality hadn't hit yet well now it's
an elitist town like it's so [__]
expensive right they're so expensive to
live in new york now that it's like you
know
it's
you know it's become this like and we
with weed is changing a little i'll say
it is changing okay because you'll smell
weed in the air now if you go to certain
areas you go to the west village down by
the comedy cellar you'll see people
smoking weed right it's not it's a it's
a little bit but not on 89th street you
want no no you ride a joint by the stand
you you're like i've been by the stand
under the joint by the stand i gotta
rest it outside of the stand i can't go
to [__] canada because of getting
arrested outside of the stadium the [__]
you think i'm talking about that's the
upper west right that's 20th no that's
uh it's a gramercy but that's yeah
yes are you kidding me that was
heroinville when i was a kid yeah
well you have needles
i didn't know that you got arrested
outside the state i did but i don't buy
this for smoking weed yeah well here's
the thing right yeah that's fine i told
you this is why i i like this what i'm
saying before i when i stop smoking weed
yeah four uh two two stars guys two
stars i can't speak anymore okay
so uh no but when i uh
when i wasn't smoking weed i was walking
around
and you'd walk past the cop and i was so
used to being fearful because i always
had weed in my pocket and now that i
didn't have wheat in my pocket it was
like a breath of fresh air like i wasn't
committing a crime at all times so cops
weren't making me as nervous you know
what i'm saying but if there was a cop
that i just literally was coming coming
like 10 feet with i would get nervous if
they could smell it on me and it's not
like you go to [__] prison for
smoking weed in new york city but it
[__] up your night it'll [__] up your
weekend if you get caught on a friday if
you get close i'm not going to join on a
friday night you'll spend the weekend in
jail we get in jail until monday
yep it [__] sucks and that's all it
is it sucks but if in canada the rules
are to get in that country you can't get
in now i i can but i gotta pay a few
hundred dollars a year and it's up to
them they could deny me the license it's
a whole bunch of [__]
that i have to go through now just to
get to canada
which is crazy
now let me ask you this because a friend
of mine said he went to
david gilmour at the guard and he had
really good seats
and somebody a little joined up and they
looked at him like [__] he can't do
it with the garden
you do the vape pen
i don't want to smoke a [__] vape pen
i want to smoke a vape pen like i want a
dick in my ass
are you [__] crazy
that's that's that's what i don't
understand
i don't know it is very dainty i used to
get like the [__] cigarettes that
women would smoke in the 40s
the like the long [__] uh ones yeah
i used to work on 11th avenue where they
sell all the cars down there yeah okay
and i used to get out of
manhattan jeep eagle in my 40s
57th okay
there's a diner on the corner there and
a hot dog man
i used to get off at work at nine
7 30. sometimes 6 30
and i remember walking up 57th street by
the cbs building and [__] and dog as
soon as i walked out of that building i
was it's 1994 that's 22 years ago i was
in my 30s
i'd walk out of there i'd make a left on
11th avenue the street would be pretty
empty until i hit 57th i started walking
up yeah as soon as i hit 57th i lit i
sparked up yeah i remember standing in
front of that david letterman building
sparking like smoking because it was too
cold
i didn't want to walk
and nobody said dick nobody looked down
their head well that's the problem with
like be like i'm addicted like that and
that's the problem i've been arrested
for smoking weed like 10 times
like
it's like people that smoke weed don't
do that like i do it to the point where
i if i'm going somewhere
and i know that i'm going to be like on
a road trip for a while and i can't
smell like i'll make them pull over and
like [__] stop at a restaurant here
like every time like i'm like i'm it's
like an addiction that's where that's
where it's not a good thing where i
literally need it every single day in
the morning
you know
i don't need alcohol
yeah
i could stay off coke for a few days but
i would never have to do it the daytime
this is my [__] drug yeah
since the time i was 12
first time i smoked it i knew it was me
yeah same thing i knew it was me
alcohol for me is something that
was something i did with other drugs you
know but it's not something that i'm
gonna go into a bar and get a beer
i wish i could be one of those guys i
grew up in the 70s where
tv shows when you walked into a guy's
apartment he just turned around and
poured you a whiskey and gave it to you
yeah you didn't say was that southern
comfort and that you just drank the
proper thing yeah
so
i always i always wanted to be that guy
that could drink i can't drink yeah
i was drinking whiskey every night for
the past [__] like eight years almost
probably killing myself like really like
just [__] my body up because at
comedy clubs we don't pay for alcohol so
i'm drinking for free every night
and um you know for i just stopped
drinking a year it'll be january 22nd
it'll be a year i don't i don't look at
it as even being a big deal i don't
understand like it's not hard for me so
i'm not applauding myself i'm not one of
these people that's going to post it on
facebook and be like oh look at what i
did who gives a [__] i'll probably make
a stupid joke about it but
it's weed is hard every day it was a
struggle when i was not smoking weed
every single day i got locked up
that was the hardest part of getting
locked up really
the thought of going to prison for me
because when i went to boulder county
for those three weeks and waiting for my
bail to get reduced they were smoking
weed in there there's no drug test in
there yeah people getting arrested and
tucking weed in their ass home bringing
it in
and you know what man like they would
charge you ten dollars for a joint or
something or ten dollars even now if you
go to just the tombs for the weekend or
the night i'm in new york city it's it
was like
this is a while ago
but it was like i think it was like 20
or 30 bucks for a joint and it was a
little tiny painter
as small as it could be you have no idea
dude crazy
and we bought it dude me and another guy
that's it done three hits but it was
great it was glorious dude
cigarettes in jail are [__] the best
i don't smoke secrets i didn't i didn't
smoke cigarettes when i went to prison i
didn't even in 87 i didn't dream of
smoking cigarettes that wasn't even i
couldn't even get in your car if you
smoked well i'm also comparing my night
in central bookings to your time in
prison no no
you might get killed at the tombs
because you might run into a guy who
don't give a [__] lee he don't give a
[__] he's already got a murder will they
mix in guys
and smoking weed
you have no [__] idea you'll see an
nyu dude a guy like you
if you went and smoked a joint in
washington square park which is a famous
place that people just get popped all
the time for smoking weed right
and that would be a place that you would
go because it seems like a place that's
pretty safe it seems like a cool if you
look look at washington square park look
at pictures it's a cool place to hang
out they got cool architecture they have
all those like [__] arches and [__]
smoking a joint out there it's like a
trap because it's it's the perfect place
to smoke a joint but they got undercover
cops all over david lee roth got
arrested there for buying weed
i knew was the end of civilization you
know in the [__] again
and you guys i'm talking to you like a
dinosaur in new york this is why when i
go to new york now it's very nice and
all but it's not the place where i grew
up in yeah i don't know these people
these people you see walking around in
new york wouldn't have walked around new
york 30 years ago yeah those people you
see walking around giggling on their
phones
that wouldn't have been i've been in new
york since 2001 right after 9 11 i moved
there and even in the time that i've
been there which is like 16 17 years
it's it's changed so dramatically my
first apartment in new york city or i'll
say let's say my second apartment
because it's more dramatic was a top
floor downtown brooklyn one stop in
downtown brooklyn top floor of a
building floor through 15 foot high
ceiling central air um the elevator came
into the kitchen brand new kitchen
washer dryer how much 1250 a month
and what is it now i don't know about
six grand seven grand easy i mean it's
crazy the apartment was not so it's 1400
square feet i had a drum set in there it
was crazy we had a ping pong table
it's so
they've uh i went to where i grew up i
went to 88 street and showed my wife and
the baby
those people would melt if they were
there when i was growing up there's like
a [__] galaxy it's like beautiful
it's beautiful 88th street it's like
you've got to see it [__] went over
there they have like people drinking
coffee 80th and what broadway i grew up
between 80th and broadway is like you
got to be a [__] rich jew like in the
industry you got to be
somebody's boss's boss to live up there
it's crazy the real estate up there is
one of the most expensive areas in the
world
yeah i love it i love the episode of new
york is it you stand up new york
ah it's been 15 years yeah i still do
that club they're cool club it's been 15
years but you know we were talking about
a
i left an 85 and cocaine was wide open
smoking joints and clubs was wide open
in those days the colombians were taking
cigarettes
taking out the tobacco and putting coke
in the front and lighting it up so it
went through a nicotine and it was like
worked like a filter
i went back in 94.
and me our buddy of mine stinky and two
girls went out
and i went to the bathroom to do a bump
the guy knocked on the door and he's
like you can't we can we don't do that
here
and i was like are you serious this is
new york city he's like we don't do that
here yeah and i remember a time before
that i went up to the upper west side i
was a young kid i was 30 something
i was doing comedy and i think i went to
stand-up new york to do one of the open
mics or something like then and then i
walked up
and i remember walking into a place like
on maybe 84th street
and it was all these people drinking
water bro
and [__] giggling and [__] i'm like
if you people would have seen what this
ball was like 20 years ago you wouldn't
have been hard it was the [__]
westies that were in there yeah four
irish dudes were in there collecting
vague and yelling there was irish music
on yeah and now it's all these [__]
gentile phases in there from college
washington square park bro
i used to go there and see chappelle as
a kid i didn't even know what stand-up
was i didn't know it was dave chappelle
i didn't know it was the other [__]
dude i had no idea when i saw miami vice
i said that's a dude from washington
square park and i looked him up i had no
idea i used to go up there with bonehead
i used to have a friend bonehead me and
stinky used to work for him and he'd
give us 50 bucks a piece to pick up a
toilet
go to the store and pick up cigarettes
and beer for him
[__] like that but the day started we
would go do it the toilet or do some
plumbing work
and then we go
to that [__] place that sells chili
and two beers or something makes all
these air houses it's still there tell
me that's still there where's it at
right washington square park right there
house
or some type of beer place i don't even
know if it's next to all these we me and
stinky would go there we'd order a beer
we were we were [__] 17.
they didn't proof you then yeah we'd
order a beer they bring us chili the
beer and he would go to the park cop
heroin
valiums yeah and weed for us
in those days you'd get eight tens eight
ten milligram volumes with the v in it
for ten dollars and he would walk back
while we were eating
he'd go into the bathroom at this place
and he'd do a little
do a little blast
just to keep him alive till eight
o'clock and then eight he'd go to
[__] zoomyville
and we did that twice a week yeah i
loved walking around washington square
park that's all i said to you yeah when
i heard david lee roth got arrested
there i go that's the end
ari said at yankee games people got the
rest of the yankee games for smoking
weed yeah
i remember going to a yankee game
and people were smoking crack
there was crack files i saw
93. here's the thing i got upset with a
guy smoking crack the other day because
i was walking down the stairs with my
kid
and it's like i live in harlem and i
like where i live in harlem is pretty
gentrified it's fairly nice what street
i live on one i mean i live i live off
of the the 116th and uh
like 7th 8th avenue that area how far
are you from la marqueta
uh just like a
12-minute walk
under like right on one side yeah we're
at 1 16th yeah still there still there
oh yeah when you make santeria i use you
know what's funny i always used to go
there that i might have said this last
time because i think you mentioned that
the last time because that building that
went down uh was right there and i i
lived a block or like a half a block
down from that building that just blew
up in harlem
um
so i used to live just a block away from
the the market right there
yeah so i have no culture i can't say
the marquetta la marquetta la marquetta
can you say it
no can i want to hear you say it walmart
my dad yeah somebody can say it later
than me i i love no i love my dad to
death but he still he calls chipotle
chipotle japan
i tell them every time i'm like dad it's
chipotle that's a new level of white and
he's like it's hey i want to i'm look
look here's the truth right like
white people see me as being like
latino you look spanish no i know yeah
my son looks spanish my son looks you
know he's the same like complexion as me
but he's only cause i'm half italian
irish and my son's only technically a
quarter hispanic but he looks just like
a [__] little puerto rican man a
great white person here because i had
shitty like really curly hair
and then it's [__] now it's just gone
now it's [__] over see that's that's
where see you think i'm young but that's
where it comes in
you gotta pay i'll do somewhere
you gotta [__] know you got great
hair joey i'm losing it it's going down
because i puff it back
the middle has puffed down it's like a
cake you don't use enough flour did you
ever see the cake on little rascals
when they [__] made the cake no
click onto little rascals the cake these
[__] need to get a dress for
their mom
so they made a cake yeah
and everybody had to pay five dollars to
get in there to eat the cake wait do you
see what they put in the [__] cake
i don't know
jesus
this is one of the best episodes of all
time then we're going to talk about what
we were talking about when uk media just
i forgot about this yeah i don't
remember what it was either what they
put in there let me get another star of
death though i feel like no other guys
are not respecting me right now we love
you to death i feel like you guys are
not respected i can't well you know what
you're going take a whatever home so
you're okay
watch this watch this [__]
look it's timey and [__]
that's petey the america's first pitbull
[Music]
this all seems very racist i don't know
why oh this that's why cosby bought him
the rapist
and he took all the racist [__] out of
it
people put the racist [__] back on
that's [__] racist
the episode is this kid here's mom gets
beat up by her husband and [__] and the
dad's a douchebag
so she wants a dress for her birthday so
these guys plan
is to make a cake and sell it and get
the prophets
to make a [__] dress
but they don't know what they're doing
they're just putting a bunch of [__] in
here yeah sugar and speed it up a little
bit lee and i'll show you this let's see
where you're at go up a little bit
all right now that they're setting up
the party
and they start throwing things into the
cake that's a little weird you know it's
funny that uh did you watch that um
stranger things show
all right
do you watch it late uh my girlfriend
has but i haven't though okay so by the
way the cast a big part of the cast is
like these little kids they're like you
know uh 10 year old kids right and
apparently they they shopped it around
to a bunch of networks and they wouldn't
sign it because it was kids and they
said nobody's gonna get on board with uh
like a kids ensemble cast
so it's kind of fun i was like you don't
really see shows that are about little
kids like who the [__] is watching this
it's like pedophiles but no this was
1930 1925.
they played these was this children was
this for children i don't know they
played was it for adults or children i
have no [__] idea when i was a kid
they were black and white and we'd watch
them you know when i was eight and nine
i watched them
and i'm like what the [__] speed this up
a little bit
and now they're putting shoes in the
[__] cake see the cake is starting to
tremulate now watch this they [__]
blow up look at this [__] this is real
stuff yeah this isn't even
special effects no they love this little
black kid look put that on louder dude
they let this little black kid almost
let himself understand look
listen to the [__] noises
oh
i haven't seen this in years i don't
even know why i thought about this
wow
this is like if this was in like why
would this look at the cake
oh my god
it's a big one
wow
so the middle of that cake that's my
hair dude you see how yeah
yeah
uh
like they didn't pay these actors they
just no they forced them to work
they made them do sex acts this is 1925.
those people were [__] terrible
this is the first black market all all
people were horrible in the tournament
horrible horrible these kids were this
was all racist yeah these kids came out
years later they were all out bees
they're missing an eye i'm sure they
tried to kill themselves they were like
[__] [__]
it was sad it was [__] sad that was
what the uh the eddie murphy sketch was
about right it was about buckwheat as an
adult
was it yeah i think that's what it was
about right
look at these [__] yeah
would you ever let your uh your kid act
no
me neither no i don't like what they get
faced with
yeah because people because i my kid's
cute as [__] my kid's a [__] cute
little boy oh no when i when she was
born the agent caught me because we set
up an account for her we should get him
in movies and [__] yeah
i saw how they picked up that kid and
sons of anarchy they put him in the
truck they made the truck roll over
you know [__] you for scale
listen man i i did five movies with kids
do you think they make the babies do
their own stunts
they have baby [__] stunt doubles you
can turn this awfully i did five movies
with kids
there were six situations that i saw
with kids i did not like in movies i did
five movies with kids
and like i always said i saw this
audition one time where the play it was
raining out
and it was [__] mobbed
and
you know people were [__] getting
rained down outside but there's this mom
and her little girl
and she had 20 headshots spread around
the floor and 20 people could have stood
there
but in her in the mom's head that was
more important her little friends look
at these pictures
i don't want my daughter around those
people that their kids
are connected with directors and [__]
like that you know yeah in my house
we're real connected with my daughter
we're not into hollywood stuff i don't
go to premieres i don't i try to avoid
as much of that hollywood stuff as i can
well also like i think the reason just
in general for the most part like
entertainment and wanting to be an
entertainer comes from some sort of
attention and i'm hoping my kid
doesn't grow up with that need because
we've given him that you know listen man
look at the final product of
six out of ten of those kids that act
yeah look at the final product
you know there's a nightmare there's
this is this if i could talk to my
daughter and say listen these people
want to use you for a show for two years
you take that money and put it up for
college
but know you going to college no matter
what happens mm-hmm know that you have
to go to college
and she's that strong yeah i would
consider it but i don't want her
mingling with those kids yeah i don't
know
i don't want to mingle with priors you
know there's just a bunch of kids that
walk around just saying that's my dad i
don't need that in my life i want you to
have your own [__] identity right do
you know what i'm saying it's real
important that you have your own [__]
identity
this new generation they can't handle
i've seen sean lennon's son what does
sean lennon do since his dad died by the
way it's the anniversary of john lennon
today uh rest in peace [__] that
album was [__] great maybe we'll
close this from john lennon also uh
dimebag daryl don bagdaro
that's right dumb i played uh i played
cowboys in hell out of [__] respect
you know
i was talking to somebody's mom a friend
of mine's wife and he was telling me how
bad the drug problem is
and like malibu high
because those people got [__] i'm
sure yeah parents are out drinking they
leave the pills in the [__] locker
room
the kids take them to school you know
it's just i see it here this is north
hollywood this is a shitty area yeah and
i've been to the y swimming with my
daughter and there's been couples there
that are there watching that kid swim
with the nanny in the pool right that's
unheard of even my mom who was a [__]
alcoholic jumped in pools with me and
jumped in the ocean with me you know
it's beyond me you're going to pay for
that later on yeah that's why like my
kid you know he he literally he's never
had like a nanny never had uh no you
know like uh
i mean we you know we got babies yeah i
got babies i got a baby set comes in
monday and fridays you know my wife out
but we don't even use her anymore yeah
we [__] we raise our kid and i have a
buddy of mine i want to say who it is
but uh he was like uh he's got he's got
money and he's like he's like god dude
he's got he had a kid like maybe two
years after i did but this is when he
had like a newborn
and he was like uh he was like yeah dude
yeah man so you know it's [__] tough
but he's like you know i loved it i'm
raising this kid you know it's just you
know really really hands-on i asked him
his schedule he was like you know so i
wake up at us you know 6 30 with her and
then uh the babysitter comes at eight or
the nanny comes at eight i go back to
sleep i'm like the [__] hour
yeah an hour and a half are you [__]
crazy some of the kids when the chicks
blowing people at the [__] prom yeah
that's when they'll come to you [__] i
shouldn't have that babysitter i should
have sat there with her and watch a
cartoon or play with blocks or something
like that my phone don't start ringing
for business until 9 30. yeah i have
mercy when i'm home and listen man i'm
no [__] best out of the yeah i'm not
here you know this is just common sense
type [__] i don't have to [__] read a
book
you when you talk to somebody you know
they're [__] broken and the more you
talk to them they start talking to my
mom or dad you know what i'm saying in
my world it's mom i don't remember my
[__] dad
we're all a little [__] broken
somewhere i think it has to be weird
just to have the option to say oh well
maybe i'll i'll do a couple commercials
and i'll pay for college like
growing up in massachusetts i didn't
know no one it was the the most anyone
had was like the job i had like a cvs
that's the problem with the cities in
l.a in new york and it's like kids grow
up fast and they also grow up i'm in the
entertainment industry so it's like
being around that it's going to be very
enticing and that's something i'm going
to have to deal with
you know in reality it's like you're
right i'm talking about my kid being
three though people put their kids at
two and three years old in commercials
and you go like you're not even giving
them a chance you're kind of you're
entrenching them in that world when they
don't have any choice and i think it's a
weird
you almost you need to have something in
you to want to get in this world so let
them figure out if they have that in in
them
it's just kind of very strange to me
that they could ever have a baby being a
[__] movie what are you doing with
your baby
bro
last night i'm sitting there stoned to
the gills i get off the phone with lee
and i notice that there's a showing
about scientology on with leah remini
have you watched it
uh she goes into science i've heard
about it but i haven't gone off on them
and she interviews different people
who abandon ship and uh
and all this [__] and blah blah blah
blah blah but there's this one guy and
she's talking to him and the guy's
crying because he left and his family
stayed in there
well you know what dog you put him in
there
do you know what i'm saying listen man
i don't like people
and i was very fortunate growing up
nobody ever took me down a dark street
okay but there's a lot of people out
there that live their life to take
people down dark streets bro
and
you get into a cult
you want to get into a cult that's your
[__] business bro yeah you can't put
your kid in there when he's [__] five
yeah
you can't do it you want to join a cult
and go to buy
whatever jonestown and drink the [__]
lemonade that's fine but i think most
people it's not guys that are in the
industry it's people that have always
wanted to be in the industry that could
never do it it's that stage mom [__]
where they want it they want to live
vicariously through their kids that is
pistol pete's dead that's that's
terrible no no so man so i think that's
why you know
like i know what it's like i mean i
haven't had a [__] easy route in this
industry so it's like i know what
rejection is like that's [__] it sucks i
wouldn't wish this like if if i would
have known back then when i first
started how tough the industry is and
how difficult it is to make a real
living here and then you know
to to [__] make it as a comedian dude
i might you know i might have picked a
different path
at this point it's just too late brother
in today's world it's tough to do
[__] anything yeah and today's
economy in today's world right now in
america it's tough to do [__]
anything
right now if you're a plumber's
apprentice right now you get out of high
school how many [__] options do you
have what are you looking for a pack i
mean i want to tap this out there's no
way to tap it i'll tap it on the floor
there and today's america
if you're a kid and you don't want to
join the service
and you like construction
and you want to join a [__] union how
much work do you think there is in the
union
you'll work steady for nine months
then the job shuts down
and to some people it's it's bad but for
you learning a trade it's even [__]
worse yeah you know how hard it is to
learn to trade in this country right now
remember 20 years ago you could walk up
to a construction site and go hey man
i'm a big guy
can i learn how to lay brick i'm going
to go have you ever had these before no
i had i learned how to be a hottie we'll
talk about laying brick yeah after a
year when you become the best hottie out
of five of them
the guy would go okay once your work is
done come on over i'll teach you how to
lay brick yeah and after five years now
you know how to lay a brick now you're
on a line you went from starting at nine
bucks or whatever it is now
to 16 17 18 an hour and after five more
years you can start your own [__]
business that's an apprenticeship
that doesn't exist no more in this
country because right now we just hire
immigrants
you know instead of labor is for
laborers we just hire immigrants i'm
sorry i have to say that word whether
they're russian like trump did or or
mexicans or guatemala and jersey they're
all years ago they were irish yeah 20
years ago
immigrants does sound like a
like a nasty word but it's not it's just
a word it's the truth they hire people
it doesn't sound like it doesn't sound
like you're like saying something like
bad like immigrants but it's just
it's it's just anybody that's not from
this country that comes here is an
immigrant well here's my question is it
they're hiring immigrants because
they're cheaper or is it is that part of
it but it's also those are the people
who are applying for the jobs like see
that's the question i don't know that i
haven't figured out okay how many kids
do you talk to today that's that 18 you
know unless your dad's in the trades and
he takes you in the summers and he
teaches you
you know how much work is for this kid
if he wants to learn a trade
that's what i always want like right now
there's three big construction projects
that we're doing the coliseum they're
doing the soccer stadium and they're
redoing some village down there or some
[__]
you know
i was thinking about that today how much
labor or work is there on that
are they doing [__] up labor where
they say they're paying the labor 16 an
hour but they bring non-union workers
and paying eight dollars flat and they
swallow the rest of the money yeah i
mean how many of those are print in
their apprentice programs i wonder how
many i haven't looked it up but tonight
i will how many apprenticeship programs
now there are
i know there was a uh i know this isn't
specifically yeah in the trades in the
trades but there was i i i did a course
and they had a i could have gone to a
trade school a vocational school they
still have that and where i grew up uh
but
i i know that there's people who make
a lot of money like i know it's kind of
a hot topic right now but people in oil
make the people who are out there
drilling are millionaires
just like millions i want to have my
child aspire to be an oil tycoon oh
listen it all starts by being an
engineer right
i don't i don't know what would you want
your little girl to be if you could
choose a career for her to be what would
it be
three careers three three that's a good
number either well you don't have no
kids right no no but you're going to one
day you're gonna [__] drop seed in a
chick oh jeez hopefully not for a while
now either a lawyer
a doctor
or some social field where she feels
she's really helping people
yeah you know there's some people that
put on this earth brother really help
people i don't give a [__] if they make
20 000 a year yeah i knew a girl years
ago that was 40 something she lived like
an artist in a [__] one-bedroom
office
you know on top of a bar
but she's like i get to help [__]
minorities every day
yeah you know there's some people are
doing that so
for me for her to have a good life she
needs to do that she needs to be a
[__] doctor
god knows how much college is going to
cost in 20 [__] years you know that's
a big fear for us
in 16 years how much is a college gonna
[__] cost at that time at that time
are you gonna really encourage your
daughter to go to college doug times
change i think in 10 years college is
going to be irrelevant i agree i'm not
in college is going to be around my kid
really well i see what's going on now
i'm watching what happened with him
i'm watching the questions we had a
conversation a few years ago that i went
home
blown away yeah you know uh by him so i
don't think it's going to be relevant
he's going to interrupt you no no please
not at all
i'm going to i'm going well i'm not
going to encourage my kid to go to
college if he wants to go like i'm not
going to be one of these parents going
like oh you got to think about college
you gotta it's gonna it's gonna be
something that he really wants to do
in general dude i tell you right now in
life i have so many friends i
most of my friends that have college
degrees most of them the vast majority
of them aren't using their degree no not
at all that's majority that's what i'm
saying there's like two that are and
then some of the teachers they're
teachers right and then some of them
their dad's paying that job it's not
great i mean to be honest with you
teaching jobs just aren't really great
fifty percent of those people their
parents paid the other fifty they're
lugging the [__] cost yeah i'm not
saying nothing bad about your parents
you guys
we split it but we split it right but
that's a crazy thing that's a loaded
thing to say they say that college is
going to be irrelevant irrelevant
irrelevant okay but then what are you
going to do because now even people drop
down they're irrelevant yeah at
mcdonald's jobs that you need to have a
college degree and and no you do but no
who the [__] is aspiring to be at a
college or a mcdonald's job that's why
when people say you gotta raise the
minimum wage i'm like why are we [__]
battling for these people that have no
aspirations i'm sorry just [__] who
wants to have minimum wage it's like two
percent of the people in the country are
make minimum wage why like you should
your thought process shouldn't be like i
want to make minimum wage the thought
process should be i want to go go beyond
that the people that are making minimum
wage should be should be they're kids
they're teenagers disabilities we don't
know about
somebody went through a traumatic
experience a divorce a debt maybe they
just want to get a job and be half a
[__] maybe serve hamburgers you know
what i'm saying mcdonald's makes a lot
of [__] money every year the same as
all these other people you're making
nine bucks an hour i'm asking you to pay
me six [__] more
and raise the [__] national average
yeah i mean
you see what it costs to be a human
being i'm not even calling listen i
didn't say the cost of life did i
i said what it cost to be a human being
none of us could afford being a human
being anymore yeah you know what's a
human being we got the best soap we got
the best shampoo we got the best rug
cleaner we got the best jackets we all
try to cut corners somewhere brother
right when we get to beverly hills we'll
get to beverly hills but for right now
we're all cutting corners somewhere if
not this office would be on top of a
condo and then have [__] right now
fan of us and [__] and we write about
the theater of the mind for the audio
listeners that's what's exactly what's
happening what's happening there's
[__] everywhere right now the
american cost of living and what an
american is making i tell you what
breaks my heart right now i know there's
thousands of people that want to go home
for their families go look at those
plane tickets
go see what it would set you back just
to get on the plane without gifts
right without gifts just the cab the two
cabs and the thing to surprise your
family it's 700 [__] dollars that's a
lot of money when you make a 400 a
[__] week my friend 500 a [__]
week right
i i don't know i'm not mad at you louis
but like no you are lee i see it in your
face i'm fear i'm furious but
i i don't necessarily think that and i
know you weren't making a blanket
statement but for uh the minimum wage i
met i worked a lot of minimum wage jobs
in high school and college
and there's a lot of people who just
like
like just me you were fine no i'm fine
now but i worked minimum wage i worked
at the kfc i know i know one of the best
experiences of my entire life was
working at kfc absolutely dude i'm
telling you right now you just it was a
one of my first jobs that i had for a
while that i had to really be
responsible with it wasn't [__]
supposed to be the be all ended i wasn't
supposed to live my life off of that job
but there are people that are willing to
do that work i just felt like it's a
very small percentage of people that
make minimum wage we should be focusing
on how can we
how can we push people to be doing jobs
and
and educating people and getting people
to do things that are beyond just the
bare minimum [__] jobs that are out
there
it's not like the good jobs are paying
minimum wage you know what i'm saying
well that's what's mcdonald pay
what is the national minimum wage right
now at this point in our lives
i don't know the national minimum wage
what is it right now well i just i've
never it's just so
tough out there guys
doing stand up there's no seven
twenty all right so seven twenty five
times forty times forty that's two
that's 300 a [__] week my friend yeah
that sucks that's 1200 a month what's
your rent
um my rent
yeah
yeah i wouldn't work for a minimum wage
oh i know but i wouldn't do it think
about how many people offer a very very
small percentage of 25
an hour i did not know i thought it was
nine dollars an hour no that's correct
and even 360 don't do nothing for it
that sounds too good that sounds so good
1300 a month you ain't doing deck with
i do stand-up comedy i've worked so
[__] hard nobody's giving me a
handout there's no minimums in my life
there's no guarantees i know but people
make the decisions people give them a
decision people make a decision to work
at mcdonald's but people may have make a
decision to work at mcdonald's because
things aren't going too well if comedy
wasn't going that great for you you'd
work at mcdonald's part-time and do
comedy part-time
but i i wouldn't i would do something
else
and i'm not saying everybody
i would never work for minimum wage as
an adult i've been going to mcdonald's
lately with my daughter
after soccer
yeah my wife and i take it to mcdonald's
i get the quarter pound i don't eat the
fries yeah
telephone good all right he's being
healthy i'm trying you run right to the
[__] bathroom that's how you know
mcdonald's is terrible i'm not even a
car and i got a [__] everything has the
same flavor like the milkshake the
french fries the burgers there's a
mcdonald's like film last time we went i
don't even need nothing and i was dying
to eat a big mac the new big mac don't
look bad they shrunk it listen
i don't [__] know is it a new big mac
there's three new big macs but i
wouldn't touch them i don't know they
broke them down i was reading it but i
was high we should get did they deliver
no we're not getting mcdonald's
delivered here that's disgusting can we
do big macs you take the [__] stink
out of this office for a year i can't
come in here i'm gonna have to get those
carpet people
what we talk about mcdonald's and i was
looking at the people working mcdonald's
right here on the
this one here i don't want to say the
name
they weren't
destitute people
they were a couple college kids the
manager you know there's a great story
that i think i told lee that the manager
the guy that created my name is earl
yeah greg garcia when the strike when he
was doing my name is earl the writer's
track he got a job
on the mcdonald's on laurel canyon the
creator yeah and he started from the
bottom washing bathrooms and [__]
and after three months they offered him
like that that's the plot of coming to
america what are you talking about he
went over there it was louis anderson's
character
this is in 2007 2008 the rider strike he
went into that mcdonald's right on
radford
and got a job at cbs right there by
where his friends are
he didn't think his friends were going
to see him and he worked and yeah he
mopped floors and they said they
promoted them to french fries and the
grill and then they got the [__]
uh
wma he [__] took the checks gave him
back to him he goes this is who i am i
just wanted to do this as an experience
oh well you know and i remember talking
to him after he goes it was so weird
that i was in there and doing this
because she tried sometimes and i've
always thought about it just getting
mcdonald's job for
me but then quitting in an awesome way
stinking like that
no i'm not going to say no no never
going to come back you want your check
not really give it the [__] uh
mcdonald land give it to ronald mcdonald
he's [__] jerk off in the fridge so
you know the last couple years since i
travel and i see what america looks like
and how different
sometimes you got to do what the [__]
you got gotta do man i think i think the
people [__] you gotta do it's just the
reality they don't even it's not that
they're not ambitious because a lot of
the most of them because they make 300 a
week have to work two jobs i don't think
that many people are look up the amount
of people in this country that are
making
uh minimum wage i'm trying to find it
but this chart's really small in mind i
think that we are talking about a very
small percentage of people maybe i'm
wrong
maybe can we get callers if calling
right now 866 522 church
866 522 church
and we want to know
we'll find out i can't
they all these charges okay all right
all right
about 1.7 million earned below the
federal wage minimum um okay but i don't
even hear the sirens but it sounds like
joey just left to go fight cops
he he he does fight
good shots come on [__] i'm doing
a podcast
all right what i think it's
okay so there's 3.3 percent
of the hourly paid workers
um
so yeah okay so it's 3.3 of the
population
3.3 yeah
that's still a lot of people though
that's with how many people in the
product give me the number of people
because here's the thing
it's 3.3 percent of the population makes
minimum wage okay 78.2 okay in 2015 78.2
million workers aged 16 and older in the
united states were paid at hourly rates
representing
58.5 percent of all wages and salary
workers
among those paid by the hour eight
hundred and seventy thousand earned
exactly the federal minimum wage
and one point seven had wages below the
federal minimum wage
you know what so that's not that's fine
78 million not that many people
it's bad out there
you said something very interesting
you worked at kentucky fried chicken how
old were you i was uh 16 to like
for like a year and a half two years if
your son comes to you when he's 15 and
goes dad i want to climb two years i
want a camaro what are you going to say
i'm going to go go work and [__]
fried chicken whatever you make put away
i'm at you
would you say something like that yeah
probably that's that's
crazy is that that
listen man you always want the best for
your children you uh
you sit there and you go
for some reason i'm very cautious about
this you know when my mom died there was
nothing i thought there was millions and
there was nothing
my mom was still married so he got no
will he gets first dabs that's crazy i
uh the same thing my parents are both
dead zero like i hear about people
getting an inheritance and i'm like
inheritance i got [__] crazy i lost
so i just lost you always want to
prepare i watch people get in harrison
like oh you gain something like i'm kind
of jealous in a weird way when people's
family members die but you always want
to prepare for your child you always go
you know what let me prepare for her
yeah in case i drop dead doing [__]
jiu jitsu or doing bong hits or stars of
death with these two [__] savages
and then you start thinking about
realities okay what do you want your
child to do i always think about can i
take mercy to 148th street and drop her
off at [__] mr gomez's house for the
weekend so she could stay with the sun
could i do this i trust you yeah
but could they do what we were doing 20
years ago walk down the riverside drive
home to the bridge
walk back around broadway walk up to
150th street go to block parties could
you would you trust your child to do
that at 10 like i did right i don't know
anymore no i'm not 10. i was doing it at
[__] six at six
six i was walking around walking the
riverside drive crossing across broadway
i used to live on uh
and up in uh washington high student
there's [__] like literally children
like two three-year-old kids out there
with no parents like an older brother
will be there like but that older
brother is like seven or eight but i'm
talking about like two in the morning
three in the morning and you go you're
like alright dude well this is i'm
telling you right now those kids if they
do if they don't end up selling drugs
and being criminals if they don't
then that is a [__] miracle good for
that guy who gets out of that because
it's nearly impossible if that's what
you're growing up in just in the [__]
hood
it's bad still dude up in the heights
there's little pockets that are nice but
here's the thing the further you get
away from centralized manhattan like
whatever burrow it is it's really it's
it's it's something you get off the bus
from jersey
on the george washington bridge can i
still get weed and coke right in that
area it's not on the street as much too
because they clean up the streets a lot
you'd have to like you look like a
[__] cop there's no way i you look
you look like you walked right off the
lawn order and you'd be trying to buy
drugs with me there's no way you
wouldn't get it
i wouldn't get it lee wouldn't get it
nope you'd have to be like a puerto
rican kid or a dominican kid or you'd
have to know somebody you'd have to live
in that area and have a guy that you
know but all they have to say is you go
to the store two or three days in a row
um you know you buy blunt wraps you know
they see you you say what's up a few
times you'll be fine after like a few
days but there's nothing on the streets
like when i left there in the 80s there
is but there's like there's hood guys
that are like hustling
that you're not even just in the hood
like you'll go times you'll be more
likely to go down to like west 4th
street by the comedy cellar or like
you know um you know union square area
if you walk around union square at night
on a weekend they'll be like black dudes
or puerto rican dudes will walk around
like oh you want weed you want coke you
can get it from those guys but you got
to kind of like just get lucky and pass
one of those dudes but there's not
really dudes nobody dependable
if you live in the hood yes there's guys
that are hanging out in [__]
stairwells that you can go to but you
got to live there you can't just walk up
by yourself there's no way
it's changed a lot
yeah i could buy
i could get off 178th street
walk three blocks near direction
30 years ago 20 years ago and buy a gun
that's crazy coke heroin weed
i didn't know meth or anything like that
i wouldn't know that
to get a gun the first one this all
right so you walk off
back in those days
this is how easy this is how crazy it
was
in those days you walked off
uh
port authority you walked onto broadway
and
you know i'm gonna [__] up the streets
you get off 178 176
you walk two blocks
and they used to be on the corner there
was a cuban place
and i would go in there sit down
you know talk to people like just talk
to
me
whatever i'd order and eat and then from
there
i would walk around the block to that
park there's a park right there i'm not
good with names
this is i bought a few guns there in 85
and then
i bought and sold a few guns there in
93.
so it was like you could just like walk
up and it was almost like walked up
almost like a pawn shop when i forgot
playing basketball out there and they
used to be a handball court and i always
tell people somebody told me this
30 years ago they when you want to buy a
gun go to a handball car
because they're all ex-felons out there
playing handball it's not like you know
every once in a while cops get out there
and play handball but besides that it's
a shitty it's a shitty sport it's a
shitty sport but that's what you learn
to play in prison so you talk [__] you
want to hype it
is that is that where
hamburg got popular as president i don't
know i don't know the [__] history of
handball i'm just telling the other
[__] you know
but i used to go there in the mid 80s
because the the word on the street was
if you had a car and you wanted to get
rid of it
you got
off like you were going to the west side
highway
and then you got off
and right under there used to be a
bridge and there was a street that oval
dog and those days they had to pull up
your car there so that street
was connected to that park the people
who ran that park
ran that street i'm gonna walk home from
the basketball court they would take the
cars that was their last mission of the
day they would take the cars and sell
them you would just drop your car off
come back tomorrow your car was
guaranteed gone in the bronx chopped up
by [__] three immigrants on its way
to [__] saudi arabia yeah that's the
truth that's the truth route
so it was all connected so somebody told
me yeah just go to the park if you want
to buy a piece
and one day i went over that i bought 22
for like 55 bucks what it must have shot
80 people this gun was good
it was good it was wow what was the one
movie where they that's how they
describe it they're like how many bodies
are on the ground yeah yeah that's what
the list is like juice or one of those
yeah if you buy a gun on the street you
want it to be [__] heavy-duty you
want this is the gun that killed kennedy
i thought the less
the less bodies on it the more valuable
the gun was because then the less the
cops are looking for well the cops are
looking for this gun so they they catch
you they're going to pin you with 18
so you better get it and shoot the
[__] quick kill somebody throw
it away the only thing that's good about
this gun is that don't miss this is how
[__] ghetto people are though that
like you bought it for 50 bucks right
you shoot somebody gonna probably sell
it back to them for 25 bucks so why
would you just get rid of it why even
waste your time throw it into the
[__] river i shoot somebody with a
gun i do something bad like i did
something once with a gun that was brand
new 600 bucks for this gun i threw it
away yeah you got it done
couldn't you just
throw gun how many guns you think are
just in the [__]
river oh
my god oh my god right under the bridge
people just shot somebody and they're
driving over they just throw it you go
right where the bridge ends you get a
stick you got a bunch of divers to just
drop
they'll pick up machine guns [__]
grenades
[__] submarines
i'm scared
a body pops up in the hudson every
[__] day yeah some something from his
body has to decompose into the water
yeah the fungi toenail the [__]
armpit rest something happened
that water used to jump into the water
because i grew up in rockland county new
york oh [__] yeah 914. yeah dude [__] it
was 845 now but back then yeah before
when i grew up
will come down and jump into the hudson
river
literally jump off that bridge when only
with a high tide were coming because
when the low tide was coming you'll
break your [__] legs but when the
high tide was in there was a certain
time of day you would jump off the penny
bridge but then they also had like
[__] wooden planks so people would
like shred up their legs jumping off
this thing
but that's the type of [__] boredom
you had when you were 12
in the suburbs of new york
you that that you you're looking for
crazy [__] to do so it's almost a weird
balance because no matter where you
raise your kid whether it's a city or a
suburbs you have to worry about your kid
[__] either becoming a drug addict or
[__] killing themselves because of
boredom
well here's the beauty of this
and this is not yet
years ago rogan said to me he got stuck
in an airport one day
and then he saw these people jumping up
and down and he goes you know they were
cuban
and he goes it made me think of you and
put a smile on my face because i got to
see what you're really about he goes
there was eight of them and they were
having a [__] parade at the terminal
yeah like they were taking over the term
like music on they were dancing
in the 80s it's it's not a joke but in
the 80s when you grow up in the suburbs
of new york
brooklyn
the bronx queens you know the hudson
river is like [__] south beach
you know what i'm saying so if even if
you watch
kaplan there's a scene where
two black black couple yell at stallone
they go hey man you [__] are
racist and [__] and that was that's
every weekend
because to them they don't want to go
down the jersey shore they don't want to
go to a nice beach to them and puerto
ricans were the best
they would pull up like with a [__]
four-door car right
with tinted windows and i was in the
four doors that opened and 19 people
walk out but then the trunk would pop
open and out of that trunk dog they
pulled out two coolers a pig
four conga drums it was on
and they would take that little corner
they would
clean the [__] grill off and they'd
go fishing in the huts oh yeah i would
go fishing are you crazy you might have
seen lucy's family i grew up fishing in
the hudson that's not even weird and
take fishes out that [__] is the worst
that's worse than katrina fish there we
go crabbing in the hudson oh we got
fishy in there yeah what do you think
[__] how many bodies are we just
talking about you got metal poisoning i
went both
johnny lopez that was crazy used to
shoot around he used to shoot cats and
dogs on they but him and his whole
family was crazy the mother wasn't
cancer and they used to sell her pills
her pain pills they were 55 dollars a
piece they were called tumenol i mean
they're just a crazy family nice people
though i like them he took his fish
he took me and divo fishing one time the
hudson river and we're out there we got
a couple six eight packs we're drinking
we're smoking no drugs and we're fishing
and also devo pulls out this [__]
fish
like this eel
yeah they've got tons of eels in the
hudson river yeah i did and you catch
eels in your line all the time and you
let them go oh he slit the heart out and
we ate it we ate the [__] heart like
this
is that like i think people
americans i'll tell you this much i
don't even know what it is we've at
least nailed the not eating weird parts
of animals because in every other
culture they [__] eat everything dude
it's disgusting
that
heart lit like ugh
elite an eel you read a tongue
i ate rabbit once and it [__] me up a
little bit
here's all that [__] [__] me up
can i tell you why because it's so i had
a little leg right it was like nothing
frog too same thing these little dainty
things you're like dude you're killing a
[__] animal it doesn't matter it's
smaller i guess you get more meat
i mean you're taking the life of this
animal right for almost nothing for like
a bite of meat we're not primitive it's
not like we're just [__] catching
something
there's no reason people don't want to
say they ate frog
somebody comes at me and goes oh my god
we had frog for dinner i want to back
candy in the mouth because
yeah who would eat a [__] frog i did
it in puerto rico i didn't pour i did
rabbit and frog because i wanted to try
it yeah one time you my [__] wife
eats
those people it was blizzards not liz's
my wife's family eats those [__]
squirrels
that's crazy they're from tennessee and
they get squirrel and barbecue or
barbecue sauce yeah they eat the legs
and [__] whatever to each his own i'm
like you know i like brain bro when i
was a kid
stop [__] with the mic i know one of
the best things my wife my mom used to
make when i was like puerto ricans cook
uh baccalato frito
those little fish [__] smelly fish
the fish that's grinded down they deep
fry it with flour
and they get out they come back a little
frito but my mom used to make those
things but uh she used to make
frittata
so with some animals brains oh
and she would take the shield off
[__] soak them an egg
flour slice them thin and deep fry those
[__] with some lemon on it yeah
when i was a kid i i watched them just
[__] yeah delicious you had to make
believe i didn't even know what the [__]
they were but she would cook them so
well you don't know what they were oh no
i knew what they were she would slice
them so thin and cook them that both
sides were just like
a half inch apart so you never even
tasted the brain you just tasted the
crispy stuff i had a [__] spicy tuna
roll when i was 11 and i almost puked
that was like the most exotic thing that
i ever had in my entire life sushi yeah
i love it oh please all right i [__]
love it i'll eat sushi i hate sushi
sushi with this [__] i went to sushi
i went to sushi last night with bruce
buffer he told us to go to that place
katana right next to the comedy store
yeah how much you dropped 280 dude dude
it was [__] crazy he was like we were
bringing him we told him that before we
should have told him afterwards
dude he [__] he killed you dude he
killed us
the voice of the ufc [__] beat us
down what would you drop in there like
400 some dollars
i wasn't even drinking well no you can't
drink in there
i made the mistake of taking somebody
there once on business and they ordered
three little steak sticks that delicious
that's that's what it was
those things are like 20 pieces i know
we're sitting there watching it leave
forget it i'm watching bruce buffer just
[__] eat four of them just
one bite at a time every time he eats
when you're like i hope he's gonna suck
my dick because if this is a girl at
least he would suck go ahead have
another one and every time they eat one
or they mangle it like a joint you're
like go ahead
i'll [__] break your finger you
better eat that
let me get another three of those oh my
god
you know who took me there one time joe
rogan
and joe rogan this gotta be eight years
ago ten years ago yeah we were at the
store and we were starving he goes you
want sushi i got joe i got eight dollars
in my pocket what do i give a [__] i'm
not gonna lie to you i thought we were
gonna pink doc to get a sandwich yeah i
had enough for a sandwich and an iced
tea he's like no we're gonna let sushi
go dog before we go in there i got eight
dollars because i don't give a [__] come
on
i looked at the menu
they were like 20 bucks for three right
how much for three sticks
uh no no it's more than that it it was i
don't know what it was it was i think
they're like nine dollars each second
twelve dollars each set first [__]
time you order three three table three
dishes um yeah my heart just sunk i'm
like i hope i don't get this checked
yeah and then he started ordering sakes
and soups and i'm looking at this and
i'm playing 12s 18. it's just crazy it's
just everything everything
24.
and i'm getting more and more
embarrassed no no no
i don't like that [__] at all listen
down the corner there's a great little
sushi spot bruce buffer it's 12.99
all you can eat
there's literally one like across the
street oh my god it's something isn't
i love eating good but there's some
places you just avoid
you know when i say to you let's go out
to dinner let's go out to dinner once
you start owning those 12 cocktails my
leg starts tapping yeah you know after i
count the second one i'm like what the
[__] are we going for here this is just
80 in cocktails i've never seen that
because i don't drink yeah i don't like
my friend he's got a sister that they
heard her husband boyfriend go out every
night they go on facebook they're always
drinking a pale ale from this place yeah
and she just had to take another
part-time job and i go that's cause
they're drinking
they cannot be surviving on what they're
making drinking every night it's pretty
crazy dude
being a comedian it was easy because
you're not paying for [__]
but how people could go out and be in
alcohol and go out to bars every night
is beyond me especially there's still
dive bars in the city correct that you
go into four dollars dives i mean very
few when i started drinking in new york
city i was 20 years old we started going
to a place called the village idiot on
14th street and 9th avenue and that
place was [__] garbage like it's
stunk like you walk in and it's smelly
you can smell the butter place down the
corner from there across the street
good fellas pizza is that still
know but this place was a [__] like
the type of place where all the
bartenders were just [__] in
bras but they were like trashy they
weren't even hot they were just [__]
like [__] chicks
and uh it was like peanut shells all
over the floor but it was it was five
dollars and fifty cents for a bud ice
pitcher
a pitcher and then it was a two dollar
shot of like well whiskey so we would
get [__] and literally twenty dollars
you walk in you're annihilated dude just
[__] annihilated and you we would
just get into fights we would [__]
checks in the bathroom it was like the
craziest time
um so yeah i guess that but i don't know
any place that's like that in new york
city where it's cheap like legitimately
cheap there used to be a place called
manhattan honda is that close to that
14th and i think it's 14th and 8th see
where manhattan honda is lee if it's
still in there
and i used to have a friend that worked
at manhattan honda so he would tell me
if you're ever in the city come over and
say hello we'll grab a cocktail and then
i had a girlfriend who lived across the
street so it was like stealing i'd go
see her and then i'd go meet corki and
we'd walk down to this bar
that was where is it
it's on 11th 11th yes it was close to
this
dealership yeah the car dealership you
really did so funny all of your
references about new york are based off
of where car dealerships are this guy
worked there so he introduced me to a
certain that part of new york he knew
all those bars and [__]
so one night me my buddy the gearhead
who's now a freeholder in north bergen
and that guy
i met him over there we went for a drink
and we go to this place on it had to be
i don't know if that's 11th and whatever
this is two blocks away either or and
it's like that bar shells on the floor
yeah a little stage a bartender who was
hooked on crack just got out of rehab
yeah she just picked up the shift
because she walked in here it's with
that movie coyote ugly or the bar is
like it's like a torah trap but that's
what it kind of pretends to be okay
you're right this place was nearly that
this place was only packed on the
weekends and it was
like a couple like college students that
were probably doing heroin and [__] like
that
i'm in there one night
and there's this black chick that you
could tell she sucked a thousand dicks
yeah but she's at the ball working at
jack
she got half a titties uh
and the black dude sits next to her and
that song comes on what's your man got
to do with me i got him everything so
i'm not trying to butcher and he just
starts yelling at her
and he's trying to work her at the bar
and she's saying no and that song was i
never forget this i'm on the other end
[__] up there's pizza shells
everywhere
some chicks getting you can't go in the
men's bathroom because some shit's
[__] in there yeah it was crazy this
place i don't know that you described
something close to it
and then but all i remember is this this
guy kept saying what's your man got to
do with me
what's your man got to do with me
what's your man got to do with me i said
[__] i gotta get the [__] out of here
yeah what's your man got to do with me i
miss all that part in new york yeah it's
[__] it's hard now man especially
it's so funny because comedians
in the beginning there's no money at all
like at all it's nearly impossible to
make anybody deal with comedy in the
beginning so it's like you're in the
tough the best place to do it is new
york city or l.a but to be honest like i
think new york city to begin and to
learn how to do comedy i think that's
that's one of the best yeah there's more
places
you know so freedom yeah yeah so i think
like it's it's just kind of a weird
ironic thing that
it's such an expensive city to live in
just the cost of living is so expensive
but then there's no money for the first
few years so you're just struggling you
can't breathe for the first few years
doing comedy in new york what here's the
deal she got a really [__] wife i
went to new york for nine months in 93
and i was rocking and rolling within
two or three weeks what is rocking them
wrong with me
i was doing five cents a week
there were 13 comics in the room
yeah you know but for where i had come
from from colorado it was dick oh yeah
yeah that's this is 94. and if all you
care about is stage time and [__] yeah
you know
that's it dude oh yeah but i always
found a way to make a pretty good living
yeah and i wasn't selling drugs like
apartheid how are you making money when
you were in new york city okay
i got hooked up a friend of mine hooked
me up
at the time it was called virginia can i
take a piss dude you're so bad i want to
hear this yeah go ahead take your time
yes sir what's up [__]
oh my goodness first off i'd like to
thank csotv
for uh putting my special on there i
don't know if you guys know it we were
the number one uh all-time premier
special
and this is thank to you guys man you
guys uh
helped me out with this i really needed
this for ceso and
you know everybody's happy you guys made
my [__] year so
thank you very much for being very loyal
and you know i love you guys with all my
heart and all that [__] so that that's
worked out well i got him in there
let me give us some shout outs real
quick
first off uh i want to shout out again
to the death squad and church families
for really coming together
from bobby sharon and crystal right now
having a they're listening right now
we're viewing party
to kyle wallace to dustin and oasis
to jason uh
i don't [__] know silverback surfer
david nolasco ratliff 307
ceco ookie spooky
tracy the church family
turned michael who came to three [__]
shows you know everybody who supported
the podcast i love you [__]
with all my art man
thank you very much for everything
you've done for us that's all
i wanted to tell you right now i wanted
to take that
and tell you that you made my [__]
year this is the best christmas present
i've ever had so
thank you very much i'm saying i'm
[__] up too lee don't feel too bad no
i'm i'm i'm a little [__] i'm i'm
what what what what what is zika
i'm not super [__] up yeah you want me
ready for another one let's do it
this will put us at what 16 16
[__] hundred kilometers of
death
catch it what are you looking away for
you want one yeah you're gonna go for
600 you're come on guys you're already
cross-side when you're talking come on
guys it looks like i think you guys
really you think that i'm a [__] i i've
been smoking
almost every day since i was uh
almost 18 years old listen just hit you
a different way yeah and if you're not
used to these if you eat 600 and walk
out of here yeah oh my god you're a
legend you're a [__] legend no shut
up oh please you're a legend you walk
out of here with six hundred dude i'll
walk
out with a thousand i will do it no you
won't i swear to god
i swear to god oh you want yourself okay
tomorrow i'll get a call that they uh
call the hospital no that's for the
dictatorship anxiety attacks yeah bro
there's no way
i've taken the amount of time
it's just a drug
no i know is it not the th it does not
affect affect you the same way that
smoking it affects you no
no not even close
i don't know the science behind it but
i'm telling you right now it's just thc
now call joe rogan he'll tell you an
hour
it turns to something else in your liver
and it becomes hallucinogenic and you
[__] ass owen benjamin asked red band
when he called the ambulance twice no
yeah he had to pull over on the one hand
how many how many have to how many do
you have to pull over this was years ago
when it first started the craze nobody
really knew
nobody really knew what exactly it did
to you so yeah pop one
interesting question
for some no it's not interesting quite
interesting before
it's funny because ever since
the last the last week
i've really been thinking about 1993 in
my life
yeah that was a really
deciding factor in my life to why i got
here
that was the first decision big year
well what happened was
i got divorced i was broke i was out of
options and i had to move back to new
york
and i really wanted to do comment like i
was doing comedy about a year and a half
but part time
i was doing it like here and there to
pick up a [__] [__] or whatever
yeah i really i
were you because i remember my first
year of doing comedy i pretended that i
didn't want to do comedy i was just
hosting shows and i was like i don't
really know i wasn't even hosting i was
doing three minutes here two minutes
here and see i was inconsistent i
wouldn't write blah blah blah but when i
went to new york i went out at night
but immediately when i went to new york
i got a job
dropping off packages for uh
it's amazing like how much hustle there
was back then
there was a job dropping off packages
hello packages to businesses for like
18t i forgot virginia and something yeah
it was like an att division at that time
i had i had that job for like two or
three months and the kid goes you know
what we're going to switch it to
brooklyn and i didn't want to go to
brooklyn every day like they were going
to move zones i was with them towards
the end of new jersey and all of
manhattan and up in manhattan there was
three or four of us they paid us 400
a week and all we had to do was drop all
20 packages bro like it wasn't hard at
all
and then i wanted them backstage is that
still out in new york yeah but
all those things are kind of dying now
because of the internet the internet so
but those things it's out there yeah but
those things had jobs all catered to
comedians
yeah
selling it making insurance appointments
what are you [__] kidding me they
give you 10 an hour
and 25 an appointment and 35 more if
they sell the [__] you know stupid
[__] yeah but you're making a living dog
but you got to focus on it
you gotta [__] focus on it but i was
like 17 year old dude they had i had a
[__] it was like a whole
like 30 [__] telemarketers in a room
just calling up old people trying to get
them to uh it's like
refinancing their mortgages yeah our
whole goal and i have no idea it was the
shadiest business was to get their
social security number you get the
social security number you got 12 bucks
you got everything else you got oh my
god
so we were literally just we were
destroying these old people's lives they
had teenagers doing it we didn't give a
[__] dude because you get that 12 every
time 12 so if you were good i was a
monster i was i just knew numbers dude
there's a ratio boom play the ratios
keep on going keep on going keep on
going keep on going and i was just just
dialing like a [__]
it was an awesome job but i know that i
ruined probably three or four hundred
people's lives completely
old people probably a few suicides in
there
it's like your family's just losing it
all
i don't know what they did with the
social security numbers it wasn't good
no no because before this before the
internet so nobody could look it up dude
there was no like it was the better
business bureau at the time like there
was like there was internet at this time
but it was like you'd have to like go to
the better business bureau website and
look up to see if somebody took a claim
now there's [__] yelp for everything
so you can easily find out if somebody's
shady in terms of business but back then
you could [__] people were just
crushing it oh it's amazing i sit here
sometimes look you were talking about
lighters before and stealing stupid [__]
for a long time when i was in my real
loser fate of life my mentality was if
you're that stupid to leave it then i'm
going to steal it yeah which is a
horrible mentality well not but somebody
learns a lesson yeah i'm saying i think
it's if you get away with it i feel like
there was a movie where they talked
about that it was a great scene in the
movie but i was like if you can get away
with it you can't that's your payment
you know what i'm saying which i kind of
under there's like a uh you know the
you know an honor on an honor and
thievery type of mentality which i kind
of i always like in a movie like i
always kind of root for the thieves and
like you know that always kind of plays
to me in a weird way i grew up [__]
like i thought my mom would my mom would
teach me to to steal [__] testers
when we go to baxter's pharmacy and
she's like yeah i go and like to take me
like the perfume testers and if they
catch you tell them it's my birthday and
start crying
it was embedded in my head when i was
like six and seven years old that's like
some crazy [__] no my mom didn't like
buying that unless they were stolen it's
crazy unless somebody brought us
something stolen from a truck yeah
i don't want nothing i don't want
nothing it's funny that uh
just gonna [__] tell you something i
forgot what the [__] it was god damn it
it's funny that you said that before i i
you know you just had these wild
fantasies as a father and what you want
for your child you know yeah
and i sit here sometimes ago you know i
said that statement lee because first of
all
i'm gonna talk her into
like i would talk your son into lee
when he's 17 and he comes to mangoes
uncle joe you think i should be on the
[__] radio like you and my dad i'm
like oh [__] no
it was a different time then you know
there was hookers and [__] now i'm gonna
go you know maybe go to college but not
right now i want you to learn something
first
i want you to learn about people i want
you to learn about human
nature and i think the best thing
to teach somebody about that is belly to
belly sales yeah better belly sales
makes you realize this [__] is out
there
i'm going out to my car for my license
i'll be right back what happened to that
guy he didn't say that are you that
stupid
are you that [__] moronic no but he
said don't believe nobody and then you
really learn about society and after a
year come back to me in a year
that you keep one job steady for one
year you don't give a [__] you're just
gonna grind it out yeah there's nothing
better out there it's just a job
you're gonna live at home you're gonna
eat at home i'll even give you a little
[__] extra spend i'll make your car
payment do this for a year yeah
and i'll help you out you can bank your
money and i'll give you 50 i'm saying
like just so they learn
what's out there before listen man
most people and even me
as [__] slick as i thought i was
when i was going to college
once you decide you got to do something
with your life it's [__] scary we've
had this conversation before lee four
years is over [__]
four years is over the diploma you got
to become a phi beta kappa you got your
dick sucked now you got to go find the
[__] job it's [__] scary out there
i always feel like it's starting over
you're going to find the job now you got
to go through now you have to learn how
to find a job yeah learn how to find a
job then learn the ends you got to start
from the bottom of that bottom again
it's like 10 years later you've wasted
your whole life on some [__] job you
hate you're you're now you're 28 to 30
years old you wasted your whole life
you're like holy [__] dude i [__]
hate this and this is what i have to do
that's what sucks about the school model
and that [__] thing i think like i
would encourage my kid to be an
entrepreneur
i would encourage my kid to [__] you
know
not necessarily like
you know
i i want him to like come to me here's
the thing right he's in preschool right
now this is what i love about his
preschool it's like a play based
preschool and they have all these
stations set up when he walks in and the
idea is he goes to what he wants to do
and then the teachers come around to
these different stations with the kids
and they kind of as the kids are playing
uh they kind of inject the lessons about
math and reading and the different
things that they can do around what the
kids are kind of interested in so it's
it's a pretty progressive kind of cool
way of teaching these little kids and i
think that's kind of a microcosm for for
kind of how i want my kid to like look
at life and how he how he does things
and chooses to do things in life like do
what you want to do you'll figure out
how to make the money around it it's an
old stupid [__] saying you know do
what you love and the money will follow
yeah but it's legitimately a real thing
and i kind of believe that you know i
believe it too i believe it in terms
it takes a lot of courage to believe it
it takes a lot of courage to sell it to
people but
if you dive into something and you
wholeheartedly die but like when i dove
into stand-up dog i don't i bought it i
bought the whole flag i knew
what my i got a job at a comedy club and
asked the comics questions
and even though they all said you don't
want to do this you don't want to do
that i knew that what they were avoiding
and that's why they're somewhere else
now yeah i was never scared of work or
hard work yeah i knew that for four
years you got to live like a nomad what
does that mean you can't have much
that's it can't have much well that's
like it's like comedy college it's
comedy you you go out there you make it
there's very few people
you know there's like two or three that
make any money before that like you know
like it's it's not even an exaggeration
there's very it just doesn't happen so
you're paying your dues but that's what
i'm saying before about being in new
york
because that's a [__] tough place to
pay your dues
la's great dude bring your dudes out
here you [__] it's beautiful weather
rent's cheap yeah but everywhere you're
gonna pay your dues this time i paid my
dues in denver and seattle
you know
i'm in the beginning you're just an open
mic both of those places have uh legal
weed now which is kind of interesting
they're [__] crazy so back then i
still know what it's like
i started in denver and i
was an open mic
and then after three or four months
you're like [__] this job
yeah you're like [__] this job i want to
be a comedian and then you go into this
life of death
it just becomes zero i was living off my
credit cards and then once they went
awry
mr gomez i was [__] you know and i
started hustling i learned how to put
together hustles like one of the hustles
that you said to me what did you do in
jersey lee take notes [__]
my buddy hashtag came to me
and he goes
die
uh
i'm gonna buy a car
you could use it
what i want you to do is pay me off the
car i'm buying it for 200
you could use it around jersey don't
take it into the city i'm gonna get
insurance for here
but it's your car pretty much he goes i
want you to become partners for me on my
breakfast
he goes
think about it let me know what you
think i asked him what he goes i got
people coming in but i really want to
build my delivery service what do you
think
and i thought about it for a week and i
went back i was doing comedy and i was
really into the comedy scene i wasn't
getting nowhere though i was just
bombing in new york every night you paid
three dollars to give you a drink ticket
yeah but in those people some places you
had to bring people in those days
some places as long as you brought the
three dollars and you got the drink
ticket they didn't give a [__] if you
bought and that's what i did i just
zipped into places did six minutes
bombed and would ask myself what the
[__] am i doing i said the one thing
that's cool now is in new york there's a
whole open mic community where there's
no feed nothing like that you just go up
and they said no
no that's i knew it would grow at this
time it was still a lot of clubs a lot
of action
seven nights a week there were [__]
ten open mics in new york and all the
five barrels it's tremendous jersey i
would go to this [__] st rocco's play
i mean it was just it was just great you
know but i wasn't getting nowhere i was
spinning my [__] wheels it was the
beginning you know
so i said i got to figure out a way how
to make a [__] living too in those
days it was 25 a gram for cut and 35 for
uncut
right on 178th street weed was ten and
five dollars still
i wasn't doing bad with that either
because all i had to do was go over the
bridge for people and [__] like that
so i figured out a way to get i i went
into i went into hash way one day i got
a dog i need for you to pay me eight
bucks an hour to make phone calls
and i called all the
i wanted the yellow pages and i got all
the businesses in the area
i got in the car and i would any place
that was a mile away body shops
anything and i went in and go let me get
your facts down i'm gonna fax your menu
every day
and every day i get that [__] 9 30
and i'd start faxing numbers
just press it was one sheet just press
the numbers
and i'd be there for 30 minutes and talk
next thing you know order started coming
in he went from three deliveries a day
to 10 yeah to 15 to 25 what's the soup
of the day
it was my own [__] department you
know i was walking out of that one time
bro i was in shock when i did the math
now
i was making 80 dollars a day in tips
that's 400
plus another [__] you know he was
giving me another two or three hundred a
week yeah i was making 2 800 delivering
[__] sandwiches though
2800 that's great and still wasn't
paying my bills
and i was [__] doing open mics and i
was probably driving a limo i had eight
jobs at one time when i was in new york
when i was an open mic
i mean that's just i was i had a big nut
and i had a big addiction yeah and uh i
had to pay rent i had no car i had to cl
i had the hash waste car and then i got
a job driving limos because the guy gave
me a [__] limo
it was tough man yeah it's tough out
there i can't imagine now where they've
cut some of the hustles
you know now what are you going to do if
you just want to sell weed see an open
mica can sell weed i think the problem
now is like people also
they get to keep on going on because
everyone's online everyone's
interconnected everyone knows what's
going on so people aren't like dropping
off as much like and then also in new
york now it's not even like that it's
not like 10 of mike's now literally in
new york city there's like
without even exaggeration there's
probably 200 shows going on tonight if
you count everything
between all the five boroughs easily now
the comedy seller is packed
the stand this pack
there's two rooms they've got the
village on a comedy cell the village
underground which is packed huge room
comedy cellar village underground is
packed
uh the stand is packed
um and then there's just a bunch of
clubs in new york
gotham's always doing well you're a
comedy club is that al martin still yeah
i'm orange in new york oh no he sold the
new york comedy he sold it okay he's
broadway still and he's got another one
right by the comedy show called
greenwich village
so i mean there's there's like there's
like 15 clubs but then there's all of
the other there's independent rooms
there's like another like 30 like
cool like independent bar shows that are
like hip and like you know the industry
comes to and then there's a bunch of
shitty open mics and
craziness but yeah it's great dude new
york new york's a thriving place but
it's also a [__] [__] ton of comics
that aren't doing anything
and it's like there's no barrier of
entry so it's just kind of like the
competition just keeps on rolling in you
know me i'd rather right now if i was an
open mic
i go to michigan i go to chicago
develop and go to houston develop an act
first and then come and have empty i go
to portland i go to seattle there's so
many markets that you could go in you're
still gonna struggle but it's gonna be a
little easier struggle you're gonna live
with three dudes
in a two-bedroom you might have to live
on the couch or under the stairway
but you know you're gonna be a bar back
three nights a week yeah probably and
also a movie theater when you come to
new york city or la and i started in new
york city and you know i know dude
you're [__] starting off being
somebody where everyone has their eyes
on you is you're not good at comedy yet
you're not gonna be good for a few years
so if you work for a few years outside
of new york
get good yeah and then come there you
have you know 15 minutes that you can
impress people with you're going to be
in a good position well brody went to
new york when he had 20 minutes 15 years
ago yeah you know that was good he was
developing in seattle mitch hedberg
already had an hour or two when he moved
to new york yeah you know that's one
thing you know here's the thing if
you're good you'll make an impression
right away yeah i mean people want you
to think people want good comedy
it's it's like you know and there's a
lot of [__] comics you kind of stand out
when you're good in new york
what about just as a person like not as
a a comedian is it still worth it to
live in new york city what do you mean
as a person yeah because like it's
always been that's what you want to do
everyone's a [__] rock star in new
york the attitude in new york city is if
a celebrity walks past you on the street
just the j if you work in a [__] bank
or the library your attitude is like ah
who gives a [__] i don't give a [__]
because the the average banker thinks
that they're the [__] rock star of
their bank you know what i'm saying so
there's like an almost like you ain't
[__] type of attitude in new york city
so you almost have to kind of have that
if you want to go there because i don't
think anybody's going to new york city
to kind of be happy and can content with
not
making it quote unquote in whatever
industry you're going into it's too it's
too high of a risk why wouldn't you just
move to the suburbs and do something
else you know
okay
i see what you're saying i mean i don't
really think i'm that cutthroat but it's
always been
a dream of mine to live in new york city
so i mean i think eventually at some
point
not really no
i mean i'm in the industry but i'm not i
don't
think i want to do stand-up um
but i don't know ever since i was a kid
visiting new york from boston it's just
i love boston and i like it
it's my home but
new york is a different feeling new york
as soon as you get soon i remember
getting because i always used to take
those buses and they would drive through
harlem and as soon as you get into
harlem it's it's it's it's a different
feeling please start screaming because
black people are approaching the bus oh
it's terrifying
but um i had an allusion to grandeur
moving my family in new york i always
liked the idea walking around the upper
west side
holding hands and walking to the school
like i did
and doing spots then i got the reality i
couldn't afford to live on the upper
west side
so i have to live in [__] middle new
jersey somewhere which i wouldn't know
you could afford to live in the upper
[__] no [__]
i'm not moving into a [__] apartment
no well that's the thing you're not
gonna [__] have like i'm sure what
you have out here is [__] no no no no
no i can't go backwards but you could
afford for in reality right you got a
daughter and a wife is that it yeah i
need two bed no no no no no
i need three bedrooms all together okay
for a three bedroom apartment up what's
up were you used to 88th and broadway
yeah it's i mean you walk
you can find you can find it for you can
find it for five if you really look now
probably six seven listen man i wouldn't
want to put my side i wouldn't want to
start the month minus seven for a
[__] apartment yeah it's expensive
with a rat downstairs and well no no no
no no no no winter ice cream i can't do
it i'm thinking in terms of a one
bedroom which is like yeah yeah no no no
check that price out lee what a question
yeah
wait what would you do in new york
though you just want to do like uh i'm
not i'm not going anywhere anytime soon
i'm just saying one day yeah eventually
it would like it just seems like a place
the place to be i i honestly thought
i'm trying looking for these stats no
it's okay um
i honestly
thought when i was going to college and
i would end up in new york i didn't
think i'd be in nelly
but i i got a i got a job offer so yeah
yeah dude i didn't [__] do i i didn't
[__] like new york at all when i
first uh moved there really yeah i would
visit with my friends like once in a
while when i was like in my teenage
years and it was just too much dude
there's too much [__] craziness and
too much noise but then you start to
realize that that's only like times
square like that's not like oh yeah i
hate times square
[__] you know little like cool areas
you go to chelsea or like you know
hell's kitchen or like in the lower east
side there's like cool pockets that
aren't like
chaotic like that
but
yeah dude it's [__] i don't know man
i i
new york city is a [__] i don't i
don't know if i want to raise my kid for
the rest of my life in new york city so
oh yeah like that's the thing i don't
think you could i mean granted it's
these are just my opinions uh without
having a kid but i don't know if you
could raise a kid in the city so that's
why if i did it it would be before i had
kids that's why i'm no you i do raise a
kid in the city we currently live in the
city with a kid
is it is it harder it's way harder i
mean i'll tell you right now like not
driving like dude here's the thing when
i live in new york city with a child you
got to leave a half an hour early for
everything that you would just do alone
just [__] walking dude he walks and
you can't [__] drag him you get
[__] like my mom i probably would
have just dragged me and [__]
grabbing my leg and dragged me down the
street when you came man but
you can't do that you know so you
literally gotta walk your [__] kid
and he's now in an age where he just is
too big for me to put him on my
shoulders
he's [__] almost four he's he's big too
um
so yeah it's
a lot harder man you know it's also like
it's like kind of [__] dirtier like
you know i got my hand i want my kid's
hand on a [__] guardrail on this new
york city subway
i just thought about the money
i thought about the wintertime i thought
about the nut i would have to make
i thought about to drive to kennedy
airport in newark or whatever
and i thought about my life here that
you know i'd have to move lee out at
first to do the podcast find him in the
[__] apartment
you know you know
they would be living in [__] oh lee
would love it on a couch in coney island
yeah lee would live in tony i would have
to live on a couch these prices are up
but ridiculous and you look at what nut
you have to make and you have to be
realistic i'm not thirty [__] oh it's
32 you could sell me a boat about
anything and i would think about it and
go now i know what that nut is i know
what that nut is i know what that nut is
at the beginning
and i know what the [__] cabs are
there's something about um
[Music]
there's something about like
i almost feel like mentally i really
mean this you know it's with sales too
so like let's say you had a sales goal
right whatever the sales goal was for
the month right
just typically you know if they made the
sales goal let's say five more units
that month or the next month
you hit it you hit the goal you know
what i'm saying so if the if the nut
needs to be bigger i just think is it
with a sales mentality you would just
make it bigger or not you know i agree
with you i would do that i've been doing
that all my life so you were just that's
not the problem i don't think it would
change your life
i'm paying seven g's for a [__]
apartment is it seven years all right so
what three g's a month that could be
going into an account for my daughter
okay so there's downtown midtown no no
upper west side upper west side okay and
you want a three bedroom yeah a walk up
starts at six thousand oh walk up and an
elevator doorman starts it's 72 grand
just to pay rent eight grand for an
elevator you want an elevator door man
dude you don't want to [__] walk out
no that's what i'm saying no no no i
dream about walking the [__] fight
that's what i do every [__] day go
back i walk around going you know what
i'm going to move out of here because
there's no [__] steps i want to walk
up four flights of [__] steps i see
steps i get
oh dude
it's [__] 98 degrees it's humid as
[__] there's dirt in the air you can't
breathe you gotta walk up subway steps
sometimes you find you hit a certain
thing where you're like deep in brooklyn
and you realize you had to walk up like
four flights of stairs on the subway in
the summer it's [__] awful dude and
then you gotta do it with a baby now
imagine you got a three-year-old that
you got to carry up these [__] stairs
it's craziness
no thank you 53 eight g's a month so
when i look at something now i have to
look at it for the family how does this
affect the family
i have friends that have kids and they
put themselves in holes
and and look at them and i go how can
you put yourself in this hole yeah to be
cool you don't have to have like a
motorcycle or somebody [__] crazy
yeah every movement i make
is around my family it has to work out
for them of course you know i tell
people people get pissed off being on my
schedule i got a crazy thing about my
school my agent called me last night
he said these people offered you this
you should definitely think and i said
what week is in the game of the week i
go that's three weeks a month
i go i got a rule he goes yeah but you
should really do it listen
tell what i got i got a family
i got a podcast but i got my health
those are all my jobs i told you a year
ago
it's two weeks a month i don't care what
you throw at me
i don't give a [__]
you know when i'm in town here on
fridays and saturdays i'm with them bro
yeah i don't really like this week i'm
not doing comedy i do comedy next i
gotta start from scratch anyway this
special came out it's over
congratulations by the way no no no it's
a lot of
so
you know when i any move i make i got to
think about my family
i know you were friends and would type
but every move i may have to think about
them how does it affect them
you know these people call you for all
this [__] and they get pissed at you and
you're like you don't understand that
doesn't benefit them
i can't take them with me to [__] i just
got a call for some comedy festival in
louisiana and the guy called me back
he's like i don't understand why you
can't do it i go the money's [__]
terrible
and i can see if i brought my family
down on me but i'm losing you're taking
me away from my family for a third of
what i make i can't i gotta stay at home
with them
i don't want to be that comic that goes
on a road every week and then has a
stroke in [__] connecticut one
weekend now i can't go on the road no
yeah we have lives man i don't want to
be that guy i saw what that does to
people
every week to be on the road [__] you my
friend [__] you i need to reduce my
batteries i need to be with my family
yeah i like taking my door to school and
picking her up and
you know going to lunch with my wife to
some shitty taco place or going to see a
movie i don't want my life to be when i
was 30 yeah i could do all that [__] i
could do did you see a rival by the way
a rival no i didn't see nothing oh
great [__] movie but you got a kid
dude it's the worst
it's brutal dude you got a [__]
daughter oh my god you're gonna see a
rival joey do you cry movies ever all
the time okay you're gonna [__] i mean
and i mean this joey what kind of movie
is it it's uh it's like oh will smith no
no it's a sci-fi it's like it's [__]
well first of all stop right there
i don't do sci-fi let me tell you joey
it's got like 98 percent of rotten
tomatoes listen
is
you listen to me it's a great movie
everyone loves it it's going to win
every [__] award this year
that's great i'm not everybody but now
listen to me
it's not it's not it's not your typical
[__] sci-fi movie okay
the trailer on can you watch it sure
are you are you watching the trailer i'm
late okay let's see here listen to me
it's a good movie but it will [__] it
will break your heart sure would you
watch it on
tv if it came out no
best movie one of the women's best movie
of the year i haven't seen avatar
there's a lot of movies avatars think so
that's stupid this isn't like that dude
there's a lot of movies or the movies of
the year that i could tell just by
looking at no this isn't sci-fi like
that dude i'm telling you right now
watch the trailer you got to watch it
it's [__] cool oh he's not going to
watch this great put it on yeah sure
whatever well you know what did you see
it no i i i i recognize the trailer
i keep forgetting what he knows me well
you know he's seen people pitch me to
that purpose
he has he knows that there's people
waiting for me at movie theaters oh my
gosh i'm sorry for giggling listen i'll
tell you i'll meet you yeah we'll go
tomorrow
i'll meet you there four o'clock wait
for me i'll be there
buy me a buy popcorn
buy me a soda [__] nachos sure
i set it up
all right here we go
that's amy adams that's the only reason
why we're gonna see this movie so cause
she's hot yeah i like her yeah she's
cute she's beautiful she's irish just
how i like them red hair and dirty i
love white chicks dude that's oh i love
them that's right is your wife white
[__] yeah irish like this i [__] love
it white chicks are the best everyone's
a list when it comes to twitch okay so
this doesn't look like sci-fi so far
where are they from you'll be reporting
to me but you'll be working with him
when you're in the show that's what
they're calling the
ufo out of three actors i like see
it's a giant turd
who's being carted off in the medevac
not everyone is wired for what you're
about to do
so what do they look like
they'll see you soon enough
every 18 hours a door opens up that's
where we go in
she's the language specialist
and they're like they're communicating
with these aliens
all right turn it off it's over yeah you
just said the word aliens that's it no
we don't know what they are yet it's
just a bird
i don't give a [__] if it's two birds
you know this [__] forest whitaker in
his eye that's okay that's i i see
the foreign this is one of twelve
i'm never gonna be able to speak their
words got two days figure something out
i am human
it's their language
we need to make sure that's great dude
i'm getting goosebumps right now it's
really good it's good
i'm happy
turn this [__] off
you're killing me over here it's [__]
crazy [__] took a 10 minute minute
gap out of
podcast that looks good take this [__]
me with the
off warships and martians let me tell
you something you will [__] you will
cry
you will cry
your eyes out
no he won't because he's not gonna see
it i'm not gonna go see it trust me oh
my god my wife would go [__] and give me
a review
that was great anyway my wife likes
these movies
i don't like i don't like sci-fi either
i hate it i like i don't like drama i
don't like sad movies you know i like
all that [__] i didn't hit russians dan
soder do you know dan no he's a [__]
great company he bought me a ticket to
see this movie i didn't know i was like
i don't want to see i didn't know what
it was he was like dude it's great
everyone said it's great i was like fine
sad [__] movie i don't like sad
movies i've dealt with sadness in my
life so i don't need to watch fake
[__] sadness it's so funny to me that
people go and watch it's only people
i don't remember it dude i remember when
i was a kid i don't remember they jumped
in the pool yeah yeah that was okay i
didn't want to see that either but
that's a sad [__] sci-fi movie it was
a sad
it's good when somebody dies somebody
gets shot in the head it don't bother me
much i like comedy i don't like movies
that are designed to make you cry
well rocky ain't designed to make you
cry cry like a [__] which one though
all of them no rocky one who cries of
rocky three
mr t no i don't think so
but i cried to all of them pop base
again
rocky i love you all that [__] makes me
go [__] anything with uh any
godfather got shot in the beginning i
cried anything about being a dad
like that [__] like now there's all the
kids movies too you know how many
[__] dads get killed in kids movies
now good dinosaur
[__] uh
you know lion king which is good baby's
mom gets killed you got to prepare
they could come so you got to sit them
down and go listen
i snorted a couple ounces in my day ate
some bad ass
i swam in the hudson i had crabs from
the hudson i hang out with puerto rican
people
most people live to their 74 most men i
might not make it there so number one
let's do the best we can
and number two i'm just letting you know
people disappear from time to time
you gotta let them know do you with your
daughter when a person dies because i
don't even know how to really deal with
it because his grandpa just died is uh
his mom's father
and you know she you know he doesn't
really get it he's four no i don't get
it but in the movies they kind of like
so happy
his grandpa died
i mean listen he just doesn't give a
[__] you know he's not there at the end
my dad died when i was that age when i
was four years old my wife
my wife's father looks like [__]
herman munster
if my daughter if he dies and my
daughter had to go back and see him in
that box it would shock her for her wife
she didn't want to know what the [__]
this is oh yeah no no we didn't bring
them together you wouldn't know what the
[__] this is they don't understand that
i thought i don't think i understood my
dad's death at three i don't think my
mom took me down there my mom
understands
my mom told me at four i remember my mom
telling me i remember the blue sheets on
my grandma's bed
she on my great grandma's bed she sat me
down she said oh your dad your dad died
he's in heaven now she was crying and i
remembered not really feeling much you
know did you go to the wake no oh that's
what i'm saying yeah i didn't go to the
wake i mean my mom telling me he died
and i didn't really understand it for
about a year
but i didn't go my mom didn't take me to
the weight it was just no no no
i see that it's kind of [__] up of
that right yeah it's not that age
because you're you're so sensitive that
you're programming them it's like to
deal with that type of [__] i don't know
you know one of the worst things i ever
did as a kid when i was about 10 or 11
and you say new jersey my mom had the
bar
this little boy and girl got kidnapped
a little boy and girl got kidnapped they
were missing for five days
and they found both of them caught up
dead
and i'll never forget that for some
reason or another i decided to go to the
wake
jesus like i was just a young kid for no
reason i watched it on the news it
bothered me so much how old were you
maybe eight nine ten what
and i walked i was at mckinley so i no
no i wasn't at mckinley it was the
summer of catholic school and i walked
to union city
and i stood online
and i walked past two did you dress did
you dress like anything or you were just
[__] dressed like a little kid just
dressed like a little kid
i just something about those two kids
dying i felt like i was connected to at
that age i don't know why
i just didn't know why i saw it on the
news and i felt so [__] bad and after
that
i remember that i never talked to nobody
in a [__] car like when people pulled
up next to me what the [__] you're
talking about
it was really weird how these are the
things you fear for for your child man
you don't know how to break it down to
life but that was then you could [__]
we were walking around and i was in the
suburbs so i was in the city but even
then the supplements were [__] up too
there was pedophiles out in the suburbs
i believe
that we were talking about this
you know about this a couple weeks ago
yeah i mean we were [__] walking
around my mom i mean
from the time i was five
on i mean four or five on my sister's
two years older than me she kind of
watched me a little bit but we would
just go out i mean we would disappear
for the whole day that's it did your
parents talk to you about pedophilia
when you were five or four ever my dad
was murdered when i was four my mom
my mom was pretty open with like a lot
of [__] crazy [__] like i was like i
knew what sex was my mom was like
you know it's almost like open to a
fault like she uh she didn't she [__]
up she was kind of she was trying to
like be open about [__] and like teach
her kids my mom too she's just [__] up
she didn't get how to do it the right
way she the the idea was right but she
[__] missed the target lee you ready
for those star death star of death lisa
lisa
lisa yeah um i i think now about the
mistakes my mom made that i don't want
to make with mercy
i don't want to tell him i'm not going
to tell my daughter i'm a standard for
however long i could hide it yeah
however long the other day she came
running in the office
and i was trying to everything they
would send me notes
for the special this is about two weeks
ago they wanted me to cut the beginning
i left he immediately looked at it
and i took it home and i i we went home
i went home that next day i was trying
to write the minutes and she came in
and she goes daddy
and i thought she was on the couch and
she didn't catch it and she ran out she
goes mommy mommy daddy's on the computer
i'm the popular
whatever the [__] she says
that my wife wants peter michael pewter
computer and then my daughter goes look
mommy
and then i said something but she never
really caught it yeah and a couple weeks
ago at school
something happened where they asked her
is your dad funny and she goes nah and
they all laughed and they were like he
came in today and they said i said you
know guys
don't [__] say no they asked me at my
kids preschool because i i wrote it on
the thing that i'm a comedian that's
what your occupation was i should just
write radio because i worked at serious
exam
um but they were like oh would you want
to come in and do jokes with the kids i
was like lady do you know what the [__]
i do like and then she told me she
looked me up afterwards at the parent
teacher she was like she was like yeah i
know we get it i said look i'll come i
know to juggle and i'll like joke around
with the kids and you could tell them
that i i work in like radio and stuff
like that we can maybe come in and they
can record their own radio show because
you know but my kid thinks i do
podcasting for work because i do a lot
of podcasting so you know he knows like
you know when i go out to my studio and
you know
yeah he doesn't understand what stand-up
is you know and i tell him i tell
ridiculous jokes like i [__] like my
kid you know he should never i curse
around them
no i try not to i'm really trying to
if i curse it he's like no dad but then
he catches me but then he gets to
[__] say because he knows what he's
doing so i'll say [__] and he'll like
he's like dad you can't say [__] and
then i'm like i'm like james you know
you can't say he's like yeah but you
can't say that i'm like oh no [__]
kid got me she hasn't got me yet
[__] got me that's playing why i
love you so much
i'll tell you the main reason why i love
you so much
the last time you went here you [__]
me up because i left here and i thought
about somebody who was really important
to me growing up like he was a big
bridge
and
we're trying to put it together you know
he's got the hiv
yeah you know so uh i remind you of a
guy that has air
bro when he when we were 16 he didn't
have the hiv right all right but he was
one of the most solid dudes i ever met
he was cuban and french
yeah his name was dede canton he's got a
brother carlos
and dede was a bridge like i think about
dede now
like dog this guy he's called manchild
he was fighting men when he was 15. yeah
i mean he was a badass [__] yeah
we got into some [__] [__] when we
were kids you know i told his brother
some of the stories because hey you know
you guys are doing that [__] i'm like
[__] yeah we were robbing gas stations
in 1516 yeah we thought we had to figure
it out right he had a devilish smile
like you
but you know what my mom died he took
right to me and every day we'd go back
to his house and his mom would feed me
and [__]
they would give me the biggest piece of
chicken and he would get mad as mama why
does he get the big piece of chicken
because his mother died that's why all
right eat your [__] chicken
and you remind me a lot of them man i
think about didi a lot now let me tell
you how deep he went
just to tell you this guy people women
would come up to me girls in high school
come up to me and go
how do we get with him
yeah he was like a ladies man
you know we were friends till high
school i left in 83 we lost contact his
brother was wanted they were looking to
kill his [__] brother some gangsters
and right before i laughed they were
looking to kill me too not the same
people and i was at the shop right one
of those places like in [__] the
other end of jersey and who do i see
that's so funny shop right such a
[__] where i grew up like things
everywhere yeah yeah i saw carlos and i
go carlos and he goes don't tell nobody
you saw me i could call us they're
looking for me too he started laughing
that's the last time i saw it
years later i go home and i go what
about the video like bro you better sit
down
and they go this [__]
because when we were kids we did a lot
of acid bro there was a lot of nights
that we just went straight like there
was no recovery
we just did acid every night we did ask
it for a week straight and we'd take two
nights off and then his brother would go
out and we'd wait for his brother we'd
do a quaalude and we'd drink a bottle of
pupa
vodka and we wait for his brother to
come home we'd sit there until he gave
us a line of coke
we were 15 16 we're [__] kids man you
know
years later they told me he was the guy
that pulled up next to you in the car
and ask you what are you doing right now
on a bicycle with no shirt on
and he was just blowing guys at hudson
county park
he just somewhere the mental health came
in yeah he had mental health issues in
his family
he got the hip from intravenous shooting
and all that stuff over the years they
just found them
if i'm 53 he's got to be 49
they say that
you know he looks good he looks healthy
for having that but he's working at a
whatever the [__] you call it
salvation army loading trucks he lives
there too yeah
he's putting it together yeah i'm sorry
it's rough
we grew up together but his family was
known for having mental health issues
yeah even the brother now when i talk to
him sometimes it's funny in conversation
he goes you know my memory is not that
good i got hit in the head with a pipe a
few years back and it [__] me up and
when he says that every time i laugh
because every time i see him he always
says the same [__] thing for me
providence [__] rhode island
how you feeling 600 milligrams i feel
good man your face is starting to change
now i'm telling you right eyeballs are
ready i listen i think i can [__]
dance i'm telling you right now don't
dance don't no dancing no i'm not a good
dancer no dancing but i i'm i think the
the challenge is there so 400 milligrams
i walk out i'm a legend 600 i'm what did
you eat this other one i hate the other
one yeah so i'm at 600 600 you're a
legend i'm a legend all right let me
know that i'm getting a lot of [__]
respect here from me brother good first
off a lot of people come in here crying
there's a lot of people i don't even say
that until because i know they won't eat
it i don't know listen i don't want
everybody to eat it
you know when you came in the first time
you came with a reputation so i just
wanted you to yeah loosen up you came in
a little you were a little you know
and this should have loosened you up
yeah lee how you feeling look at lee
this i think this might be my record
sixteen hundred yeah we're gonna go for
two more hundred oh no two more hundred
two more 100 at this point
at this point you know what the only
difference the hospital bet that you
wake up tomorrow and there's tubes in
your arms you're like mr sayat do you
know why you're here and you're like
uh
let me guess yeah i don't think my only
my insurance covers marijuana od
yeah smoke some of this oh cool man what
are you talking ab oh my god oh yeah
we're going deep into murky on the way
it's getting crazy baby
let's take another star drink a little
water oh my god i'm gonna set the record
at 1800 mr gomez here next time he comes
on
we're doing 2 000.
sure sure
what do you think of that
i think it's [__] phenomenal i'm
proud of you guys we don't [__] around
here i know i built these tolerance up
i've built my own time and stuff i work
hard i don't want to be one bro i see
these [__] guys from california
talking [__] how much reefer they smoke
i don't smoke no reefer when i show up
with my guns they melt
what do you have in there oh my god
i had to leave here and drive eight
miles and walk on the beach and meditate
what the [__] are you talking about
so i want [__] to know when
they come on here
there's a long lasting effect
you know the same two [__] just
[__] around here
we're breaking it we're going for 1800
tonight lisa
swallow that champion lee like this look
is that
[__] leave it for the mouse
look at this like that like a doctor and
[__]
okay
providence rhode island go see my man
mr gomez two shows friday two shows
saturday do me the [__] favor like
you went to see so and download it if
you're in the area go see him have a
good time bring him a [__] number if
you're abroad and you got a sore throat
sucker's dick it usually goes away you
know what i'm saying my girl my girl's a
comic so she'll be there it's christmas
time [__]
24 what is it what what look at this
poor kid look at that
money conceito look at him holding on to
the computer holding on to his nose like
i threw him in the deep end
we're gonna eat this star off the floor
we're going to split this no we're not
yeah
i'm just
pleased
oh my gosh
right there
please just go three ways what
all right we'll do it three ways do it
three ways i'm ready to go eat the star
eat the star
let's see what happens
right just like that so we went 1800
plus tonight ladies and gentlemen it's
gonna be a deep night how much 600
pounds i don't have to sleep tomorrow i
don't have to get up so i'm getting
anxiety all night i'll be breathing
heavy all [__] night
and that's it and that's that
[__] providence wrote on me
i got no [__] dates i got
nothing till the 21st of the chinese
restaurant
can i promote a couple other little bits
sure all right january 14th forget that
it's that's not even going to work
because it's too far away okay but that
time it's the holidays never mind drop
them anywhere
detroit hospital club louis gomez
january 14th myself dave smith special
guest joe list legion of skanks presents
get your tickets detroithustleclub.com
um that's gonna be crazy dude the
strippers they're [__] smoking hot
we're gonna have a really filthy dirty
show and it's gonna be crazy you're
crazy i like these strip club shows
they're pretty dope you're a bad
[__] i'm too old for those
things thank you no i go in there i look
like a creepy old man great man you fit
right in
they talked to me they asked me creepy
questions i don't do well in strip clubs
i'm not a strip club guy yeah
yeah i mean i don't here's why i went to
one last christmas by myself i ran in
and ran out can i tell you why i'm a
strip club guy and i'm a good one okay
because i don't ever pay for lap dances
i don't give a [__] about that [__] no
you don't know so i'll go and nobody
does it
they just drive corvettes because nobody
pays for that no i just go in and give
him a dollar and walk out
i'm sure you do
nobody goes to the vip and tries to
finger bang your [__] till it's [__]
bleeding to death no i'm telling you i
know you're going to hang out i don't
spend money no no you just stand back
there like johnny cool
and they all talk to you because you
know no they don't talk to me i'm just
saying the reason it's not a big deal
for me to go to strip club all right
[__] off i love you
no no you go to strip clubs you're a
disgusting young man and every once in a
while those [__] hypnotize you yeah i
got a lap dance at the destroyer detroit
hustle club and it was [__] and
that's not one you get three of them no
i got one
you got three of them you don't have to
lie nobody we're family here let them
know that you're the captain kirk of the
enterprise i go to a strip club you take
209 of the atm how much of dance 20
let's do [__] 10 throw one in for 11.
and if not let's do three give me a hand
job and suck my and drink to come
[__] and [__] we're good for the
other lap dancers yeah you can have it
you can do the breakdown whatever you
want yeah oh you don't want to dance you
can lick my nuts and [__] and [__] uh
we'll call it partners i don't give a
[__] i just can't do it you know the
last time i went to a strip club and
really enjoyed myself was blow street in
canada
bloor street in wall street in toronto
b-l-o-o-r in toronto canada it was
filthy
yeah i was biting it well yeah up in
montreal you're allowed to play with the
titties yeah no it's filthy i like all
that dirty [__] but to sit down like a
half a [__] and look at your [__]
i gotta pay eighty dollars to [__]
finger you forget about it you know i'm
not into that i'm too old i walk it
listen last christmas i went to the
comedy store on a sunday dog i went to
an atm machine i took out a deuce and i
got off of van nuys i made a u-turn i
saw a strip club and i saw a girl i
walked in there was three girls sitting
there lonely as [__]
i couldn't believe it last time i went
to a strip club there was 200 guys
and there'd be 16 girls dancing and
money would be getting thrown this place
was sad but all these three girls were
hot
and i got to the car and the one girl's
like joey joey i just watched you at the
show we listened to your podcast come in
i said so what goes on in here she gave
me a menu
i said give me a dance i got another
dance and i just broke it down i said
listen what's the story you know let me
snow that monkey what do we do here
because i can't do that okay business is
shut down
i thought it was like the old days i
could smell your titties and [__] like
that this is all far they dance four
feet away like i'm [__] easy with div
you know what i'm saying
[__] you you gonna give me the papers
lee or i'm gonna sit here like a [__]
street
for four hours i'm over here waiting
thinking he'll do it on his own but no
you didn't ask me i gotta ask you you're
the [__] producer of the show are you
not the producer
are you not the manager
yeah i have right here all right then
get it together anyway
picture a world where putting on a new
pair underwear isn't just fresh you're
stepping into a better day
you ever walk into underwear and they're
[__] tremendous
and you can feel your whole day change
you even have that that's what happens
when you put on me on these or how the
[__] do i know because that's what i
wear
every time i work out i wear me on these
why because it keeps the moisture in
because of a fabric a material called
modal that's pronounced
m-o-d-a-l
myandi's focus is solely on producing
the most comfortable underwear you've
ever experienced period my friends at
miandi sent me a pair a few pairs a
while back and now i can't imagine
wearing anything else now they sent me a
christmas collection
santa claus with white balls on my balls
[__] tremendous all right for the
price of two cocktails me and these will
deliver you a new favorite pair
underwear right to your doorstep better
day guaranteed you try them on if they
aren't the most comfortable best feeling
undies you've ever had they'll refund
you and let you keep
the first pair for free
including the price of the sweet touch
of motor a special fabric that's best in
its class raw materials that are
scientifically proven to be three times
softer than [__] cotton i'm telling
you you know how you wear the the white
underwear they listen this me undies
will change your [__] life
the uber free cozy undies are sold
exclusively on the me on these website
where you enjoy free shipping in the u.s
and canada and now because of the
holidays for a limited time
everyone in my audience gets 20 off
their first order but you have to go to
our special url
meundies.com joey again
meundies.com joey with me undies better
day guarantee you have nothing to lose
especially around the holidays worst
case scenario you got a free prayer
underwear so don't wait any longer go to
memphis.com
joey right now for 20 off your first
order that's me undies
right now for 20 off your first order
and free shipping in canada and the
united states what do you think about
that lee i love it i i i swear i get
that get the sweatpants
the the underdog the unknown hero of
meundies yeah no that's why those red
ones i have they're all [__] purpose
i only wear my north bergen shirt i'm
throwing [__] heat you know what i'm
saying how you doing louis gomez good
man you're looking around the room
you're hearing dragons and [__] i can
see that look in your eye you're
starting to look like aydah fernandez
uh i've been drinking the hidden water
here for a month in fact we're only down
to one bottle i think they sent the
sturdy whatever flavor i mean this is
great stuff
you know you should drink eight glasses
of water a day but who really does
coffee soda energy drinks this that
why don't you just drink some more water
because it's bland hey i'm the same boat
you want something that tastes good
here's the solution drink hint water
instead you know you should drink eight
glasses of water today but who really
does nobody why because it's boring
that's why you got to go to head water
okay it was started by kara golden
after her fourth child she was
overweight she had terrible acne she
felt awful she was drinking 10 of those
diet sodas a day like lee
she started drinking water but she
wouldn't like it because it was boring
but one of the options were this juice
is full of calories and no calorie
drinks or garbage that's why she started
hitting water hint is pure infused with
the taste
of fresh fruit with hint drinking water
isn't boring they have flavors to suit
any palette watermelon peach mango
grapefruit hey it's christmas time this
is a great [__] gift okay no sugar no
chemicals just great tasting all natural
fruit flavored water both health and
self magazines have named hint water the
best flavored water
because they know how important drinking
plenty of water is
to your health all right now do me a
favor please
right now
for the holidays get a single variety
pack shipped directly to your door
including three bottles of each a hints
more popular flavors pineapple
watermelon crisp apple and blackberry
normally 24 bucks i'm gonna give it to
you for fifteen dollars at drink hint
dot com slash church again normally 24
for three bottles of each of the most
popular flavors pineapple watermelon
crisp apple and blueberry blackberry
normally 24. i'm giving it to you for 15
at drink hot drink hint dot com slash
church again that's drink hint h i n t
dot com slash church again drink hint
dot com slash church happy holidays to
you bad [__] and as always i
want to thank annette the major sponsor
of the show whether it's the shroom tech
sport
the meal or the hemp force protein
they're always on point they're always
changing go to their website go to
honor.com right now and look at the
selection of supplements they have i
can't help you with the medal but as far
as supplements i'll give you 10 off and
you'll get to rock and roll and deliver
to your door mr gomez always a pleasure
to see you my brother mr sayat you bad
[__] always a pleasure to see
you what are you doing this weekend i'm
going to a pug show what is it this
weekend
what am i doing this weekend now look at
this [__] story oh we're going to try
to go to see uh that
bad 10 or 2 again with johnny rock and
his girlfriend we're gonna try to do
that
you couldn't avoid that [__] call
like it's a call from [__] uh
hitler right okay you see that number
come up don't even answer you don't want
to go to the movies with nobody how old
are we now a rifle what are they gonna
have with a propeller and [__]
i don't know why
you supposed to have a couple friends
friends i don't know not to double date
like a half a [__] and hold hands and
giggling each other's stupid jokes
another couple swap huh just do a couple
swaps yeah he won't do that we don't
come on leigh you wouldn't do that i i
don't think it'd be me you'd have to
convince to be very honest i think it'd
be
oh yeah i actually would
because then i
you always forget that your girlfriend
has to do it too so that's not gonna
happen yeah put the goddamn music on
have a great weekend i love you
[__] stay black we love you
[__]
you gotta go nowhere
my brother
[Music]
you